foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome everybody to the 2023 Junior
speech has Championship final match the
championship match I am International
Master David Bruce joined by
International Master kosty kavuzki Costa
how's it going hey David good morning
it's great to be here with you how are
you
oh fantastic fantastic looking forward
to seeing how professional you can be
um we've got a match between two very
young but already professional players
ukesh and rownx sadwani
um fantastic fantastic players child
prodigies youngest Grandmasters in
history list members
and that is starting in just 10 minutes
yeah huge final David it's a huge huge
final both these players they won a
number of very very tough matches
they're two of just the strongest
players in the world
um they're Olympic teammates as we're
going to talk about they play on the
same Olympiad together last year winning
a bronze medal for India so these two
they know each other super well they're
super strong super talented and they had
to defeat a number of strong players
just to get here so this is going to be
a huge huge final
yeah let's take a look at that um the
bracket the course that they took to get
here in the first round you know fairly
decisive victories you know winning by
the scores over 20 points
um you know I would say maybe not the
hugest surprise given given that the
field for this year's jscc had some
higher and lower players and these two
are among the strongest uh Blitz players
in the world and then in the semi-finals
it got much closer winning by a similar
score of five and six points each
um and today they face each other when
when you look over this bracket coaster
were there any results here that
particularly surprised you or is this
the final you saw coming all along
yeah there are some very interesting
matches here I was watching a few of
them I covered
um the match between Dennis lazovic his
first round match where he uh defeated
another very strong Grandmaster Daniel
Darda
um and you know by by a very wide margin
so lazovic was looking great but then he
was defeated byronic sadwani actually
that was an extremely close match but
ronic managed to just Outlast him so
um yeah ronik's path to the final I
think was was very tough gukesh also as
well in the semi-final he had to defeat
his buddy buddy pranav which was also
just incredibly uh tough match and now I
feel like both these guys are just
stronger now they've gone into the
finals they've had to play these like
difficult matches you know they've
survived they've survived the bullet and
the time scrambles and yeah now they
they have to get through one very very
tough match if they want to win today
yeah and let's have a look at what's at
stake for the player who does win and
also you know what's going to be in the
mind of both players as they're fighting
uh for this final championship there's
going to be fifteen thousand dollars at
stake just in this final match alone out
of the 45 000 prize pool for these eight
talented Juniors
um 7500 goes automatically to the winner
and then the remaining 7 500 is divided
by percentage so if you score 70 of the
total uh games in the match you get 70
of 7 500 added to your 7 500 but uh
perhaps arguably the biggest prize today
is that the winner qualifies to the main
event of the speed chess championships
um where they can face the likes of
Magnus Carlson as gukesh did in the
first round in 2022. yeah I mean this is
a lot of money uh for they're just kids
you know they're basically teenagers
they're haven't reached their uh their
20s yet but um they're playing for just
a ton of cash
um and uh yeah actually let's take a
look at um ukesh and see some of his
career highlights he is the youngest
player to beat Magnus Carlson
third youngest Grandmaster in history
2022 Olympiad individual gold medalist
he basically led the Indian Olympia team
to a bronze medal finished on board one
with absolutely amazing score uh
five-time Asian youth Championship gold
medalist
and ranking number 13 currently in the
live classical ratings
yeah and there he is Grandmaster gukesh
he was the first seed in this event
despite not having the highest chess.com
Blitz rating
um apparently he doesn't spend a lot of
time playing uh sort of casual Blitz
just
you know just just to pass the time
um unlike his opponent round neck and
you see that impressive collection of
trophies just above his head there and
uh that reminds me of one of the most
important things of gokesha's career in
my mind which is that gukesh has won a
huge number of events he's a player who
has relatively speaking like played down
more often than playing up you know he
hasn't like pushed himself to go into
the higher section he hasn't gotten a
lot of early invitations before he'd
peaked and so this is somebody who's
gone around on the open circuit crushing
tournament after tournament after
tournament he is very familiar with uh
winning the grand prize
absolutely
um and we got to say gukesh he um
uh we do have a slight bias towards
gukesh you know he was on the California
unicorns Pro chess League team which we
managed so we saw him play We rooted for
him not that we don't love ronic who is
an incredibly strong player in his own
right but I feel like we have to throw
that out there we have sengukesh in
action quite a bit Yeah there could be
some bias on this show I mean full
disclosure I I know Costa personally as
well so I'm biased in favor of my
co-commentator my question
um but let's turn the page and check out
the bio of Round Rock sadwani
um a player who I have been following
since he joined the pro chess league as
a talented International Master under
the moniker or chess champ 2005.
following his birth year art which is
his birth year
um and uh very very important here
everybody to understand this first line
here 2021 jscc runner-up meaning he
played in the same finals that we're
about to see two years ago against
another Indian teenage Prodigy uh nihal
sarin who himself is you know a blitz
and bullet demon and perhaps addict
um and uh other other accolades he is
the 2022 Abu Dhabi blitz winner which is
another big powerful Blitz event the
chess Olympiad bronze medalist as we
mentioned playing on the same team as
gokash
um and that was the B team for India one
of the most Sensational stories if not
the most Sensational story of 2022 was
these two teenage teams India B and
Uzbekistan Racing for first place in a
classical time control chess Olympiad
against all the great powerhouses to the
world
um and he's also the fourth youngest
Indian chess Grand Master so what do you
think of round x uh chances and what he
brings to this match
is an absolute beast when it comes to
online chess we can see him there I
think he we've gone in word that he's
actually in his hotel room
um in Dubai uh playing uh an upcoming
open event and uh yeah he looks ready I
saw he was bobbing a bit maybe listening
to uh to some music I think he's he's
ready to put up a big fight he's
definitely I feel like more experienced
than go cash in terms of playing lots
and lots of online chats especially like
these fast time controls five plus one
three plus one one plus one
um you know I'd imagine his Mouse skills
are maybe a little bit uh better than
Google cash
um but okay still going to be a very
very exciting and and close uh close
match
um oh it looks like we've got a smarter
chess prediction coming up so we can
compare these two players yeah within
the numbers yeah and you can compare
them with your own predictions and with
chats predictions as well
um the first thing you notice is the
blitz rating difference right Costa that
um Blue Cash despite being 100 points
higher in classical chess is here 100
points lower in his Blitz rating but
smarter chess is taking it all into
consideration and sees gooketch as a one
point favorite which would mean that you
know four hours from now the match
would be a nail biter in its last game
um so he's taking he's taking gukesh's
offline uh Power into consideration and
thinks that gookish could pull away by
one point during the three and one
segment and uh what what was your take
on this prediction
it makes a lot of sense I mean we can
see smarter chests there with the
mathematical prediction that this match
is going to be incredibly exciting and
close which I think we could uh we could
trust him on that both these two are are
Fighters and um the match is going to be
starting very very soon but uh let's
quickly take a look at a format we're
going to have three different time
controls for the match first we have 90
minutes of five minutes plus one uh
games then 60 Minutes of three plus one
as many games as they can get in before
the timer runs out and then finally
finishing up with 30 minutes of bullet
one plus one second per move but it's
not classic bullet you know it's not one
plus zero it's three plus zero these
guys they get the one second increment
which definitely changes things
and as the match is about to get started
we see Veronica there
looking very ready
yeah that one second is enough that any
situation where you've got like you know
King and pawn against king and queen
you're not going to flag the queen like
the Queen's eventually going to win the
game so there will be that degree of
sort of rational outcomes
um
and uh one other note about the match
format as the first moves are hitting
the board here is that once a game
starts it counts versus when the timer
runs out for the segment right when the
90 minutes runs out or the 60 Minutes
runs out you still get to finish
whatever game you've started even if
you've just played E4
that's right and first game is underway
looks like we have an Italian game and
David this is just like a classic
beginners beginner's Italian right like
two kids playing their first tournament
Knight C3 Knight C6 yeah it's a it's
appropriate coaster because you know the
junior speed Chess Championship is
sponsored by chess kid and uh if you
logged into chess kid right now you
could find 10 000 games in this current
position which I would call like the kid
variation of the Italian game
so what better way to kick off the match
yeah absolutely them paying tribute to
the the openings we all played as kids
or both sides I remember you just try to
get the bishop to G5 first you go for
the Knight D5 whoever gets this first
wins the game you know that's just
that's always how that's always how it
worked uh for me I don't know you had
the same experience but yeah it can be
dangerous sometimes to Castle before
playing either H3 or H6 right
um yeah and then I think when kids go
over a thousand
they have learned that you can go King
H1 and even if your pawns get doubled
you know you play Rook G1 and you don't
lose the game and it's still sort of an
interesting position exactly it's not
the end of the world even if you get the
the double Pawns in front of your king
but definitely something to avoid I feel
like we're gonna see that very very
little in in this match Blitz is a very
practical game you know it's like you
just don't want to have your king opened
up for for no reason okay now both sides
have have Castle they both spend time
before they Castle I feel like these
days you always have to actually your uh
you know high level player you have to
like double check make sure you're not
like castling into some kind of fierce
attack but there's Bishop G5
immediately immediately Rana allows the
doubling
um yeah of of the pawns and this is
interesting you know our human intuition
would say this is not good
um it doesn't like it either oh yeah I
would not want to allow this game this
is a famous maneuver from another semi
kid opening the four nights
um and it's a way of breaking that pin
as you play Knight E7 and if they don't
take you can go Knight G6 and H6 and the
bishop on G5 runs out of Runway without
you having to commit to H6 and G5 is
black and if they do take right away the
Knight on E7 covers the key weak Square
on F5
um
so
I mean if you didn't tell me the engine
labeled this as a mistake I would have
thought that's reasonable totally
reasonable no I don't know I mean it I
mean it might be objectively sound like
maybe it's playable for black but I just
feel like for Blitz I mean okay ronic
he's like 500 points stronger than me
right what am I going to teachronic
right but I'm just saying I think it's
you know
in terms of the practicality of the
decision I just feel like you know these
positions are always one mistake away
from just getting mated just getting an
immediately losing position and uh it's
very tough to play if you only have
three minutes on your clock you know
it's not a lot of time to come up with
with the best moves like in classical
chess if you have a difficult position
you can spend 20 minutes and just
calculate everything and try to figure
it out and Blitz it's like you have to
play intuitively and if the right move
isn't intuitive then it's going to be
very very hard to find but gukesh I love
what he's doing Knight H4 King H1 I feel
like this is super simple maybe he wants
to go um F4 at some point and open up
Brook Queen coming to H5
and yeah I don't know I I think it looks
good for white
yeah I mean what you said about Instinct
and intuition like I definitely think
that
one's Instinct intuition for these
positions should be to get the Kings off
the G file so King H1 King h8 Knight H4
fighting over F5 all these moves I think
were the intuitive or instinctive move
for players who have some experience
playing the G takes F6 positions
um
but uh you know we noticed the player
spending 20 seconds on every move anyway
right it's sort of like a slightly slow
pace or Blitz and I think they're
calculating a bunch of non-intuitive
moves as well you know just
they're not playing just purely by hand
uh they're both huge huge huge
calculators and they're looking at
little details that are sailing past us
right and left oh yeah absolutely I
think that's one of the things that's
maybe typical about like the new
generation of Juniors like they're all
just insane calculators just machines
they just calculate everything looking
at concrete lines they don't discard
moves just because they look bad or they
look ugly they want to objectively
analyze the position and just be as
concrete as they possibly can which
makes them very very strong I mean
that's one of the most important things
of in jazz is just having really good
and clear calculation but I think
another thing that's important is having
like the feeling like being able to play
with your hand so to speak
yeah
um so Bishop to B4 this is the first
move in the game so far that surprises
me Coast yeah yeah I think um roundek
was sort of playing around I'm gonna
play D5 while you need your Pawn for the
night I'm gonna block out that Bishop on
C4 cover the light squares even better
this bishop B4 moves a little bit
surprising because my first thought
would be that lets the Knight on C3 Just
Dance towards the king side and your
Bishop is what wandering like Knight E2
right yeah that would be my first
thought and then the bishop just looks
completely stranded on the queen side
then you can bring the Knight to like G3
H5 G7 look at all these weaknesses yeah
a lot of squares for the for the knights
yeah and you're going all the way to
within one square of the king huh yeah
and I think 92 was played and ronic has
gone D5 let's get back to the live
position so D5 was the response that
makes a lot of sense striking back in
the center before white has a chance to
just set up a completely winning attack
Bishop drops back and now Rogue G8 and
two minutes to go so it's it's
essentially uh like a three you know a
three minute Blitz game now that they've
uh that they're playing you know with
the relatively slow opening but now G3
oh this is a very interesting move to me
that was the first really really
difficult choice in the game was between
you want your knight to go through to G3
and H5 like you mentioned but you also
don't want your opponent's Knight on G6
going to F4 and H4 and opening up The
Rook so he finally chooses to play G3
and I think if he had played Knight G3
then after Knight F4
maybe that cuts his Knight off from H5
anyway and his Knight ends up just being
stuck on G3 defending the G2 Pawn for a
while so maybe he felt like he would be
stuck there might have been kind of
unpleasant here for uh for white
here's a move you have to calculate
leaving F6 undefended
and now Knight E7
on the board
C3 Bishop C5 is okay
um my sort of Tactical
he's got Rook G6 right so don't quite
but yeah you're right like F6 is hanging
so it feels like maybe there's something
there but 90 seconds for ragukesh right
and uh man this is gonna get sharp I
mean this is like such a complicated
position they're about to go into a
bullet game you know they're just going
to be relying on this one second uh
increments okay how do you deal so he
just drops back he doesn't want to trade
the night off just yet I can definitely
understand that decision and he hits F6
and now this one hanging with check Rook
G6 defending
yeah and Coach yeah I was thinking about
this move for white C3 with the idea of
countering in the center with D4 at some
point googkesh is never going to play it
because he's noticed if he ever plays C3
there's D takes E4 but that's like the
kind of little thing that I
that I would definitely miss in a Blitz
game
yeah
yeah Queen G2 was was played yeah a
little passive um for the queen but he
gets out of the way of the de4 exactly
probably for the reason you were saying
right maybe he wants to go C3 now the
Queen's like not hanging so the computer
maybe didn't understand that move but we
did yeah and as soon as he backed up the
queen ronak moved the bishop off of C5
so you can't hit with C4 with with C3
with Tempo into D4
yeah exactly so we got some logic okay
now Queen comes back to F3 ironic I
think demonstrated why the queen on G2
was a big problem Bishop H3 was just
going to be a super annoying threat
there to win The Exchange so he kind of
admits his mistake goes back but okay
now it's uh actually looking much much
better for black black is one a lot of
times he's gone in D5 in the F5 score
seems to be under extremely uh strong
control so this is no longer like even a
real weakness as soon as white play puts
a knight there in fact these
he's just rubbing it in he's like I'm
gonna go F5 wow feeling confident he had
an extra 30 seconds on the clock and it
clearly at least equal position since
white was going Queen G2 Queen F3 you
know not doing anything and Roundup
decides to go very very aggressive here
in the very first game put some pressure
on the top seed
well why not you have the two Bishops
you feel like your opponent has just
wasted uh several Tempe uh with with
their pieces so yeah why not take over
the center no no it looks uh extremely
double-edged E4 is coming at any moment
yep there we go
and oh where's this queen going that's
important if he'd been forced to trade
his e-pawn on D4 there
it would have isolated all three
remaining Central pawns right the d-pawn
of the two F pawns would have all just
been trash instead he sets up a strong
center with E4 all light squared pawns
and he's got the only dark squared
Bishop to cover
the holes that arise I don't have forces
20 seconds left
okay he's found a solid Square for his
Knights I feel like this is very
important for the upcoming scramble you
just need solid squares where's this
point queen queen
very lacking yeah there might have been
some Rook G5 there is Queen is very much
in danger of just getting caught but 15
seconds for both players so many pieces
still on the board yeah oh my God this
is gonna get violence fast
my G6 and H5 oh and here we go ironic
just going for it he's giving the
exchange doesn't take it
he wants the other one
what is happening yeah he yeah now he
could throw an F3 but I think he doesn't
even take the Knight he hits the other
one
oh yeah it is three seconds for runic
okay the moves are coming in so fast and
he sacks on G3 to play Queen D5 and then
E3
attacking the Canon
this is still incredible two seconds
left
moronic
oh my God I don't even know how they're
getting the moves off in time yeah
now Rook G6
give me the queen of square is it gonna
be a repetition here on the G final he's
got Bishop f8 oh he's got a picture of
my face that's it he trapped the queen
with two seconds on the clock
what
a find all these smokes
good start for ronak
very good start what a game
he solved like a 3500 level puzzle with
like three seconds on his clock yeah
it's like a bullet scramble it looks
like it was also like he was also
winning on the board at the end right
like he like okay who catch flagged but
because around I could traps his Queen
yeah exactly the queen had no moves okay
Queen had the entire sixth Rank and it
was all covered yeah
outrageous outrageous Roundup looks
pretty calm after after all that
yeah no problem just game one yes Monday
nights warming up
yeah
do you think anything do you think it's
an advantage to be calm when you're
playing Blitz chess
um you know that that's a great question
I think it depends I think a lot of
players they get into kind of a rush and
once they get going then they can they
get hot and they can win a lot of games
um I don't know I I generally feel like
it's probably better to keep your cool
as much as you can try to stay objective
because everyone knows once you're down
to seconds on your clock I mean the
nerves uh they can drive you crazy you
stop seeing the board correctly you stop
seeing you just start hallucinating you
know I mean the Mind freezes up right
it's it's a very stressful situation
when you're just down to Second that's
one of the most amazing things uh about
these players not the fact that they're
not like flagging in these sharp
positions the fact that they're just
playing like really strong and competent
moves on basically just seconds literal
seconds
um so yeah I feel like the calmer you
are
and I definitely feel like Magnus stays
very very calm uh generally the more it
helps you in these um
in these fast time controls yeah I'm
definitely not calm but I've never been
certain how big of a disadvantage was
but okay Kelsey thinks it may be
something that
that I could try the other way I could
try being a different person
um you could try
see see how it goes if I just decide to
be all calm about everything
um
and okay the position we've got it's uh
started as a symmetrical English turned
into kind of a scheme you see in the
king's Indian where the Knight gets kind
of stuck on A5 and black plays A6 B5
to make use of it
um because you play a lot of Kingston
Indiana's black I don't think you played
the Theon Kettle lines as white very
often but do you do you recognize this
position pretty well
yeah I'd say like there's a couple
General things we can say about this
structure so like number one white has a
lot more space thanks to this D5 Pawn
which is definitely cramping blacks
pieces especially the bishop on B7
especially the Knight on E5 so gooka
she's playing B5 this kind of thematic
Pawn break because he's trying to open
up his pieces right and um Golden Rule
of you know these positions when you
have a big space Advantage is that if
black can trade off like a minor piece
or two then generally black is
considered to be kind of fine if not if
white can keep all the minor pieces on
the board and black is definitely going
to struggle especially again Knight on
A5 looks really really bad now that the
queen side is closed up basically not
doing anything Bishop can always reroute
itself like vs C8 that's pretty easy but
this line on A5 we see this in the rui
Lopez quite often as well this dude is
just stuck stuck without a layover no
ticket no prospects yeah very very hard
time now for this so I think white is
just clearly clearly better yeah yeah
and I think there was a little sequence
that ronak played it probably was
mystifying to 99 of the people watching
uh this this game and this match but it
was basic like me as a pro as you know a
master watching I was like oh he crushed
him because he had this idea that the
Knight on A5 was undefended right so
when black plays B5
um at movie I'll just go back yeah I
know you're talking you know what I'm
talking about it was so important when
black plays B5 putting pressure on C4
if there's pressure on C4 black can open
the B file the G7 Bishop coordinates it
with the Knight on A5 has a job Etc
right but he he was planning he hits the
Knight on A5 by retreating his Knight
not 94 as Costa said 94 I looked at
Costa says trading pieces would make
Black's task a little less difficult
yeah Josie says don't trade pieces when
you have more space okay yeah so he hits
the Knight
then he hits it again and basically the
Knight you can't Retreat he forces black
to play B4 quote unquote grabbing space
but what it's doing is taking the
pressure off of C4 keeping the center
closed so that white can then eventually
unwind and squish him so that was a
really sick sequence when he hit him
with that I was like oh ronak is yeah
you know
he's got it honestly Bishop C3 is like a
double X Clan move it's a brilliant move
because you're literally like walking
into like a free tempo for the opponent
which most players are kind of taught
not to do but it completely changes the
Strategic nature of the position and now
black is just in huge strategic danger
so yeah I'm I'm absolutely with you I
think that was uh kind of a huge moment
in this game and now he's just like yeah
got all the space uh just going through
the moves we're going to catch up to the
game here Rook A1 Queen C2 and ironic
he's just building up the pressure but
she's he's looking for counter play and
he got his Knight back he got it tonight
this is classic defensive technique this
is something which I think Magnus is
maybe the best in the world at but like
this whole coming generation and we're
watching a Junior tournament this whole
coming generation generally pretty good
at it is knowing when to pitch a pawn to
set up a more active defense rather than
just suffering and that A4 because the
Knight on B7 in the end couldn't find
any Square better than A5 but now you
know C4 is undefended like the Knight
actually has a job there it's defended
by The Rook because of the pawn sack so
it's not going to be just attacked and
lost on A5 it's a very very good
practical chance uh by gukash a good
defensive play yeah look at that I mean
I I think his position looks quite he's
got like a Banco Gambit kind of thing
he's given up a Pawn on the queen side
he's got very very active pieces and
yeah now this is very annoying like
undermining the nine on E3 which is
defending C4 yeah I really like
gookesh's uh his A4 push I think that
was a very very smart and practical
decision here yeah and Knight G4 was
super important because if you don't
have Knight G4 as black white can just
plop the Knight on B5
and take away some of your counter play
your Banco counter play but now if the
Knight goes to B5 black can play Bishop
takes B5 Knight takes E3 Bishop takes B2
and then Fork White on C4 with the with
the miserable A5 Knight
and just put that on the board okay he
goes Knight D1
but he has to take with the Rook because
he got he needs to keep the bishop on B2
defended oh anyway you didn't need to
kill it he did it with the tactics and
A4 is hanging two now he's got like the
best mango
Blitz that out oh he had that one ready
he was like play Knight D1 ronak play
Knight D1 he had that ready
holy moly and now ironic's just a pawn
down and uh his lost position uh I mean
it's just it's just really really bad
black is extra Pawn protected Pastor
better Bishop yeah I mean one White's
only hope is that maybe like some H6 and
some play but
yeah time to get things converts
yeah yeah these end games are very very
nice so fun for black
and now Queen A3 is like you want to
trade Rooks or you want to trade Queens
your choice boss your choice
I I'm good either way I assure you yeah
yeah my piece will be more active than
yours you you trade on whatever you want
to do yeah but of course white did have
to trade because black was starting to
straight up win with Queen takes E3 and
then Rick takes Rook so now Rook B7
would be a saving move if black
played something casual like King to G7
um
[Music]
yeah this is still certainly gonna take
uh some work for for black like it's not
gonna be
easy here whatsoever but should be good
chances I feel like so if you go King f8
there's Rook B8 check
then you'd have to go Bishop Y8 Bishop
H3 then your life is really messy so he
just uses the C Pawn to stop White's
counter play saying you don't have time
to take on E7 here
maybe not even time to take the on D7
right like Rook B7 he might play C3 not
not Bishop to G exactly I have a feeling
with C4 he already saw like six moves
ahead so like C3 takes he's got check at
the end and then C2 and yeah he would be
uh winning White's Rook at the end here
so
um one minute for ronic to try and find
some chances to save this but it looks
good once you no longer like you can't
even get active with your Rook that's
gonna be a problem so he's gonna have to
find a way to stop the pawn maybe bishop
F1 tried to get the bishop
um to D3 might be a good way to start
bringing the king in but
yeah this is gonna be very difficult
I mean you could also still play Rook B7
with the idea of just putting it on C7
not taking anything on the seventh rank
um
right he first positions the bishop as
you say covering C2 covering E4 making
room for the king to come across
and yeah if he'd played Rook B7 to C7
right away then maybe Rook A1 from black
would have been Troublesome now he tries
to switch the Rook to cset yeah snags
the pawn now White's yeah in position to
activate the Rook but now it's two pawns
C3 pawns very well defended
and um oh he didn't take on E7 he was
definitely afraid of Bishop F3 there
which would have been very very painful
oh yeah like even here black could
consider C2 Bishop C2 Bishop F3 right
like Bishop F3 yeah
oh what a move oh Bishop three so he's
going for the meeting net he gives up
the pass Pawn oh but this is super
difficult for white E4 is gonna hang
only 20 seconds though for good catch so
he still has to uh
right like he can cover the back rank
mate for now
on B1 but that means the bishop has to
keep its Square on C2 so against like
Rook C3 or he's gonna have to go Rook B2
against Rook A2 he would have to go
Bishop B one or something
oh Rook B3 wow
okay nice move for The Rook end game
six five four for gookish oh he takes he
goes for The Rook end game I okay he's
definitely still better he's got the
extra Pawn but White's Bishop was so
passive yeah I think eval eval bar
didn't like didn't like the trade there
for black imagine just keeping the
Bishops on was was probably stronger but
only five seconds so yeah you gotta what
can you do you gotta play fast
but so here we have to check can't let
the king go to E5 great defensive
technique again
F6 I'm gonna try to play H4 for space so
maybe King H3 so that you'd have F4
check ready keep that black king back
and now maybe Mark time with the Rook no
it's by King F5 what's the thing come in
that was a very risky Choice E5 and
gukash knows he picked up a second Pawn
now it's two pawns now this feels uh
great winning chances for black Rook D2
looked much stronger last move I gotta
say that felt like a like almost like a
mouse slip like a mouse slipped
you trapped the King on H3 and then
they're sort of you know much more room
too I'm I'm with you like these kids you
know they still have lessons to learn in
the end game okay I'm with you
so you can calculate everything but they
don't have you know the hand just yet
okay D2 he's running the pawn White's
King is on G2 but this is very committal
with D2 because now Black's Brave
that was sweet
I feel like ronic is is defending this
like an absolute machine how does
Black's King get in completely boxed in
oh man what an end game
three seconds each
I mean you can still try for some kind
of mouse slip kind of situation or a
surprise move
King comes out
King's loose
it's got nowhere to hide from checks
yeah that's the problem the pawns on D2
King can't hide
only chance
sparkling defense
yeah it's just a draw
in that end game that look it looked so
winning for Gucci he's still two pawns
up it feels like you know maybe there's
something but it's hard to do anything
with the stage Pawn well you can just
ignore it and yeah exactly just give
checks
and yeah at a certain point actually
just comes trivial and draw agreed
who Kesh realizes nothing he can do with
the two pawns no reason to waste time
and uh next game that I gotta say it's
got to be disappointing for gukash feels
like that was 100 his game to win but he
went into that Rook end game we
immediately felt like oh this isn't so
easy and ironic just defended it like
wow very very clean
I would say shocking hold byronix edwani
like watching that position you would
you you would not think that more than
one out of 100 games black would avoid
losing
absolutely absolutely yeah very very
surprising that he that he held on there
okay and I like how they've now they've
switched it up they've Advanced to more
sophisticated openings they're not
playing the Knight C3 you know
beginner's Italian game now we've got a
classic Berlin this uh Bishop takes C6
exchange structure
very very very 21st century position in
fact position of the 2020s
of our decade this this variation
um yeah carwana plays these positions
Magnus plays these positions Wesley
plays these positions all the top
players now play this these positions
here
yeah in 10 short minutes we went from
kids in in 1890 to uh
the top Pros in uh 2023 so they're
giving us a tour of Chess history here
yeah I have a feeling both these guys
are going to be mixing up their openings
quite a bit
as they just try different things look
to surprise I think they they both kind
of have that in their in their Style
um now this is a very interesting
position White's given up one of their
Bishops but they've got two knights and
a nice dark squared Bishop in return and
these pieces they coordinate very well
especially when they attack uh the E5
Square
um so definitely uh quite a reasonable
approach I think from from gukesh
yeah on Knight H4 I love this the other
night Knight A5
oh man just Breaking All the Rules
but do people still go on and on about
night on the rim as grim and that kind
of stuff or have we have we moved past
it now
it still comes up you know it still
comes up sadly sadly but yeah if the
knights you know if the knights got
prospects folks they're good you know
this Knight comes back to C4 this Knight
can jump to F5
um yeah
I feel like I hear less of those sort of
silly pseudo principles now it's a lot
more of like
plus one plus one point three you know
it's just like I think a lot of people
are just much less stereotype because
they're working with computers and so
it's sort of whatever works works
yeah I think we we're definitely moving
away from a lot of the the classic
principles they're still fun to say like
all Rook end games are drawn that last
one was drawn you know it was strong
yeah so sometimes there is some wisdom
um to to these things uh but of course
chess is like it's a game of exceptions
that's what makes it so interesting and
complicated at the same time it's like
you have all these principles you have
all these rules and you have a million
situations where it's also
quite reasonable to break the rules and
try something different
yeah all right black covers the F5
Square it says
oh man but he could not take there I
mean he could take but the problem is
white just takes back with the pawn then
Bishop on E6 is still trap white wins
back the piece and Black's king would
just be wide open uh for the rest of the
game so and that's Black's best piece
that light squared Bishop so the fact
that that it's trapped and it has to
trade itself for a night then you don't
have the bishop area of weak light
squares as well as the weak King so
um the night just sits right there yeah
they're just gonna they're just gonna
play game of chicken with this Knight
why just leaving the night for I I
honestly love these kinds of positions
where you just leave the piece there for
as long because you don't want to go
back I mean you're not you're not some
kind of chicken you don't want to
retreat your night oh but he has to also
chicken Escape squirt wow no shame from
gooka she's like I don't care I provoke
the weakness you don't want that King
itch on that King H1 move coaster I was
thinking maybe Queen D2 to threat to
Knight H6 Knight F5 Queen H6 but he's
playing a higher level positional game
here he's not on that
cheap mate threats well now he's managed
to provoke black into advancing his King
side and the bishop on B2 is suddenly
awakened it's no longer biting on
granite since black pushed that five
here so yeah this is actually I think
extremely uh extremely double-edged we
might even see like F4 at some point
from White
um but yeah with F5 I mean Knight on H4
is still doing a lot of work putting a
ton of pressure on uh on G6 the most
exciting move would be Knight G6
hmm
just spraying two nights for that light
squared Bishop
opening up the king a little bit then
playing F4 it's very very speculative
yeah but it's exactly the kind of thing
you look for when you feel like your
opponent has weakened their uh for King
side he's certainly calculating
something
yeah yes
GF Queen H5 is also like a a very simple
approach trying to get into those
squares but then Queen E8
sorry it does take once a verse at all
now yeah Queen H5 Queen E8 and probably
white doesn't want the end game with
Black's King being pretty pretty weak
here I feel like you want to keep Queens
on the board you want to just get F4 in
at some point yeah well immediately I
mean I think the follow-up he's going
for is F4 here
F4 but if black takes then then how do
you take back because you have a problem
with the Knight on H4
yeah I don't know maybe then you throw
in Queen H5 Queen E8 trade queens and
then take back
he goes Queen E2 yeah feels a little
slow but I think he just wants to get
the Rook into the game sometimes in
Blitz like you just can't spend forever
even if you know like you might have
something strong it's like
oh you just gotta make moves
Costa on F4 he can now play Knight E to
F5 that's why he can permit himself this
move because the big thing about you
know me wanting to play F4 for White is
you don't want black to put all the
pawns on dark squares open up the light
Square Bishop but this tactic F4 Knight
F5 which won't come up
is an example of the kind of stuff going
on Non-Stop these guys are calculating
crazy stuff all the time takes six takes
24.
the only piece that could save The Rook
would be like the queen going to G5 but
it leaves A8 hanging on the other light
Square so oh and other Rook is hanging
as well I went I wanted both Rooks yeah
well there's Queen G5 instead of F6 and
then you only have
that's fair fair enough yeah so Queen G5
played now c4 wow fighting on the queen
side but getting some light squares
especially the D5 Square for the knights
I think C4 is still the Knight on E3 can
potentially move without allowing Bishop
D5
he's a defensive
I don't know about necessity but
you know it's kind of similar to their
their first game where ronic was
definitely a little bit weaker on the
king side but then he built up a lot of
space a lot of activity he had the two
Bishops
um but still a lot of um
a lot of weaknesses and yeah we can see
whites King especially getting in
trouble on the light squares one day if
Black's bishop ever finds itself on like
the long diagonal um which could yep
should definitely happen yeah C4 stops
Bishop D5 but definitely Bishop C8 to B7
is an option for black in in a sort of
eventual future yeah we might see that
at some point
um
yeah this is uh
this is tricky gukash a little bit up on
the clock about 20 seconds
head here trying to figure out why not
to play this I really wanted to play
Knight F6 to G4 for roundock
um which would have hung the E5 pawn and
so Bishop F7 defends E5 with the Rook
might be possible
and queen H5 looking for the end game
hmm
do you go for the end game here or do
you keep the pressure on the board I
mean it would allow us to finally play
F4 which seems like such an important
move but it gives up the factor of the
black king being exposed but the
question is is White's King so much
better
oh it's a tough decision I probably
would have just traded queens and played
F4
um
going for the end game yeah I mean
that's always what they say against the
kids you want to go for the end game but
the problem is they're both kids so can
they both go for the end game against
each other is that a valid strategy
also they're both just like so good I
think go for the end game against kids
it's like Sound Advice against a kid
rated you know 1800 or even 2 000 2100
they may have some like really strong
points and still some weaknesses once
the kid you're talking about is you know
rated 2700 feet a
I don't think there's any advice left
that's true yeah it's a little bit of
the night on the rim is dim of chess
strategies oh just go for the end game
yeah should be
should be fine hey shout out to the
twitch chat we we see you guys how's
everyone doing
um oh boy Ronald down to 20 seconds
you just played King G8 engine doesn't
like that yeah 20 seconds okay what do
you want from him right yeah he needs to
make a move got out of the way of the
queen on C2 I mean D4 is what I was
calculating for white so he got out of
the way for sure wanted that now kukash
building up it should be six and yeah
we're gonna see uh just insane scramble
once again there's just too many pieces
on the board for this not to just
completely explode now Bishop C8
remember we we thought about this bishop
comes to B7
because E5 is getting sieged
boy 97 besides the Knight needs to drop
back right it was back yeah it was a
little weird but he's covering F5 and
and defending E5 of course as well
20 seconds for both players
I I don't see any clearly good moves for
either of them
I would just be shuffling here back and
forth yeah King G1 just don't flag geez
Louise yeah he's trying not to lose the
game yeah definitely the swagging would
not be your
optimal
I don't think fighting would be would be
good
eh seven oh man they're both just trying
to get moves off in time A5 A4
preventing black from opening the a file
so now at least
falls into it finally everyone coming oh
he wins The Exchange yeah Turkish now
winning but he's only got three seconds
we're in the position still completely
look at Black's Bishops this could
easily turn turn bad Rick G8 coming yeah
if he played Rook G8 White had rookie
seven that's why he didn't go for it and
gogash flags oh no he flagged on F4
oh no he's completely winning too but
it's such a crazy position just didn't
get a move off in time
is this
a scary start for gukesh yet he
is losing on time in the five minute
games a little bit
yeah I mean I gotta say it's such a
complicated position it's a little bit
different when you know like flying in
an end game where you have like one
piece you can just move back and forth
versus flying in a position
like that I mean
oh boy
round act letting letting it sail
throwing the H Pawn up the board
yeah wow ironic's feeling it he's good
he's up two points he's happy is he in
some kind of weird opening prep as well
like is this some kind of like Blitz
opening that he's prepared at some point
you know who I've seen do this kind of
thing former world champion Vladimir
kramnik especially like online time
controls that he's really gotten into a
lot of these like funky funky English
setups but they're very dangerous I mean
black skin is already under like serious
pressure here but Knight F5 I mean they
lost some games but he's still gookash
right he's still fighting back here
right he's not going anywhere buying
long shot David to answer your question
I mean it's it's definitely a bad sign
but I would say still very very early in
the match and
um once these players get warmed up I
think it's going to be yeah very very
close in the end regardless yeah
oh there's so much going on so much to
say first of all I also had that
question about is this some kind of
opening prep or but you said maybe he's
just feeling it I think it was he's just
feeling it because that Knight F5 move
was so strong if that were a position
that he had specifically prepared before
that interchange of H5 and F4
no I think Knight F5 is too strong a
move so
um I think he was just feeling excited a
little bit and went for something juicy
yeah but now look at this I think it
turned out great for Rana because
we got opposite sides castling but
White's King just looks so much safer on
the queen side and black structure is
just so hard to uh to play with all
these pawns and Rook takes H4 The
Exchange sack and just G5 oh man wow
this thing feels a little unnecessary
not gonna lie but but we can like we can
feel the confidence right I mean what a
sack yeah he's created quite a nice
night position
um and although kukesh has the bishop
pair as well as the extra Exchange
it's hard to use Bishops and Rooks in
this position he's really ironic has
created a very very Knight
favorable position right now
it's not a very practical sacrifice I
mean he has a lot of moves he's got
Knight F3 he's got Rook to G1 coming
queen is the big question who is aiming
at the king yeah Queen EA could be
annoying hitting um on an H5 I mean I I
feel like strategically the sack has a
ton of
kind of value because Black's Bishop on
C8 is just it's not going to see the
king side anytime soon it's just kind of
stuck on the the queen side we need
nice find by gukash asking some
questions to White's H5 Pawn mainly how
are you going to defend it yeah now G6
that's how yeah now the king side is
locked up right and the H4 Pawn is not a
foregone conclusion like blackhead
consider playing you know Queen E7
Bishop F6 holding on to it and it's hard
to have a free hand on the rest of the
board when you have to deal with that
past H Pawn
right and I feel like Ronald's thinking
a little bit like why did I sack the
exchange
it could have happened yeah
yeah
fine okay well I liked his position
until I noticed Queen E8 and then I
changed my mind it takes
but this is gonna let black play F4 at
some point and then free is light score
bishop and then black is for sure doing
and
this bishop gets out
all White's gonna lose all their pawns
on the king side yeah I mean I said he
created a knight
favorable position but what do knights
hate most of all
uh
wait I know this one yeah yeah what's
their what's their like you know Nemesis
what's what's the thing that they they
have nightmares about themselves
Rook ponds yes Knights have bad dreams
about past rug pawns so that thing on H3
is like no the knights are not gonna win
this game
oh man
well it's still on gukesh to win this I
mean it's a very very sharp position
yeah and and the problem is white has
tons of play like C5 is hanging E5 is
hanging so you have to be very precise
here as black maybe F4 just invite the
end game with Queen takes C5 yeah F4
into extra materials
both look good to me E4 also just
opening up yeah with the F4 the more
obvious move to me because you can also
go you know Bishop G4 to H5 to G6 at
some point
or played
I have a feeling he's not gonna he's
gonna put like Queen E4 or something
like not
then then Bishop F5 Queen C6 and
yeah I mean just pray pretty weird right
okay your answer is to pray E4 yeah no
no it's no F4 looks very very strong I
think Google crush is in control but he
needs to win like if he doesn't win this
game then things are going to start to
really I think feel feel difficult
because I feel like in these matches
it's always about momentum especially if
someone gets off to an early lead the
other player just feels like they can't
win a game you know they're just like
behind and uh they can't do anything and
it's huge for your uh confidence and
it's not good you definitely need
confidence to um
to win uh against a strong player so I
can also imagine how it would feel for
me to play against round neck because
roundak plays unbelievable defense right
and he's very very resilient and tricky
as well and sometimes he'll even win the
positions he's losing instead of even
instead of just drawing them and that
defense and that Banco end game down the
past sea Pawn I mean
what I think can happen is you just stop
believing that you can beat the guy like
you just like how do you ever push this
guy off the ledge and you and you sort
of
yeah at a certain point it just feels
unfair frankly it just feels unfair yeah
like how many extra pieces do I need to
win a game you know I just I can't do it
yeah but once Gucci gets that first win
then I I feel like we're gonna see a big
shift in the momentum because then it's
like oh okay yeah yeah I remember now
I'm I'm good I'm the youngest player
ever to have been in Magnus Carlson you
you remember that oh yeah you're
I think it's it's kind of a thing it's
like you're only you feel like you're
only as good as as your last game right
and right now go cash is last games of
course he's probably not feeling great
about them
you should win this one cost you by the
way because I'm just realizing they're
about to hit their first break of the
match right because they've played just
about 45 minutes out of the 90 minute
five and one portion so they're probably
gonna have a short little break right
after this game it would be great if
he'd won a game when he goes into the
break
absolutely
absolutely especially if it's like if
you have chances it's not like he's been
worse in every game and and then Rana
converts it's like you know if you're
winning the game it's like yeah you feel
like you want to convert very important
now Knight C3 saronic
bringing the Knight back he's got a lot
of squares to choose from from this
night he's looking at D5 B5 E4
um so night is working night is working
and again it's
I don't know gukesh spent a lot of
time relatively on that Rook d8 move and
the current move but it felt like last
move maybe he wanted to play Rook C8 or
E4 and came up with something fancier
um because now white is trying to
prevent him from playing
look at this the counter attack
because they just have their tactics
ready and Lotus whatever it takes why a
black was gonna lose
Rook there after 97 Knight C6
yeah so he finds Queen f8
one minute left for gokish which is
relevant because he sort of run out of
his time resource while trying to
convert good positions right yeah again
the position is super complicated super
sharp and um yeah we'll see if he's able
to kind of close it out I think at a
certain point it's like you gotta go you
gotta go Bishop G4 you gotta start
taking pawns right now E5 is hanging
though so
um we'll see what he does but
yeah a certain point black has to start
winning this game
yeah if he goes to E4 there's Bishop G7
Queen G7 Knight F6 check
and it's hard to get that Night Out and
because White's gonna play D takes E4
and then E4 E5 so instead he tries to
cover the E5 Square
yeah I like rookie a covering 97 check
just in case covering the E Pawn and
yeah
um go for Bishop G4 I tried Bishop E6
maybe at some point see if I can trade
it off for
and on D5 but
yeah eventually black and Rook G1
stopping Rook G4
or Simon Bishop G4 sorry and just kind
of nice prophylactic move and yeah
asking black what are you gonna do how
are you going to convert this both Rooks
passive it's tough it's tough okay my
idea would be king h8
never mind
I want to play E4 and then put my queen
on G7 without allowing Knight F6 check
because the knight in F3 will be hit by
a pawn but anyway this move also it's
another move I thought of trying to stop
Knight F6 as well similar idea yeah but
with Tempo inviting white to grab on A7
which would give him a lot of material
this decides not to because Queen B7
interesting like he's keeping an eye on
The Rook on exactly the queen wants to
recapture on G7 right so you can't play
E4 when The Rook on C8 is hanging that's
why I sort of gave up on Rook E6 myself
wow
we're seeing the end game oh because he
gets the exchange back
but is this gonna be enough for white
because black still has a very strong
light squared bishop and H3 Pawn
wow Pawn
that's right take push H2
or within the bishop F4
yeah I guess E2 so hold on actually
white white ended up a pawn up here so
yeah I don't think yeah
ronix escaping once again
feels that way at the moment now King E2
and if hold on three Rook F1 you just
hung the D3 Pawn all right never mind
never know I changed my mind I'm I'm
flopping good Cash winning good Cash
winning he's still somewhat better but
it's not clear if it's enough to win
right now it's close I mean the the
trend just uh yeah that was huge just
picking up those two pawns now he gets
to activate the king and he's a few
seconds ahead roundex playing his moves
with less than a second on the clock
some of these moves
yeah I mean he Veronica's again defended
like an absolute Maniac
um yeah but now it's it's two pawns and
it's like a black has a very strong
control over the position as well
uh he's not gonna lose the each Pawn
anytime soon
oh it looks looks like he might be able
to get H2 in yeah he wins the bishop now
should be now should be clean for guka
she's got the extra piece he's got the H
Pawn it should be very very simple get
the Rook behind the pawn
nice and um
[Music]
oh yeah I had that moment too he's gonna
try to just convert rook and Bishop
against truck
okay he finds a way to trade Rooks and
now it's over
and um
playing it out all the way to mate yeah
or single catch the show that he can win
the game and that's it go cash picks up
his first win huge score for gukesh so
now it's gonna be a one point lead
going into the first break and we can
see he is stoic a lot a lot to talk
about in what we've just seen there a
lot to talk about but we're going to
take a very short break as the players
take a very short break there's 40
Summit 40 minutes or so of five plus one
action left in the first time control
when we come back in just a moment
everybody
[Music]
on the Gridiron success is measured in a
60-minute gauntlet of athletic
resilience and mental fortitude
the ability to outplay and out think
one's opponent is the difference between
that sweet victory and crushing defeat
and on these 64 squares much is the same
it's a battle of wheel grit and
determination minus the bone crushing
hits of course
but what happens when the two cross
paths this two seconds
oh my God for the second gear some of
the national football league's biggest
stars turned their attention from the
field to the chessboard once again oh my
God instead of in zone it's in game
instead of QB sex it's Queen sex instead
of check Downs it's checkmates all the
metaphors you can handle oh man he's
about to be Blitz Champion is the first
Blitz champion and the winner well they
get to talk about it forever
put the cleats and pads away and get
ready to lead your 16 chess men to Glory
this is Blitz Champs 2. watch all the
action live on twitch.tv slash chess and
youtube.com chess on June 23rd
hi chess parents fun Master Mike from
chess kid here are you still looking for
summer camps for your kids well our
friends at Magnus chess Academy have got
you covered there's a different summer
camp every week online just like our
lessons on chess kit these camps can be
educational but they're also a lot of
fun they're going to teach your kids
resilience and a lot of spatial
reasoning and decision making learning
from losses Positive Growth mindset a
whole bunch of other factors they're
going to make them better people as well
as better chess players just click on
the link to find out more about all of
our offerings like chess kid Magnus
chess Academy is part of the chess.com
family
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ly ahead by one point in his second jscc
final
after playing this final match as well
in 2021 here he is in 2023 with a slight
lead up one point against the top seed
gookesh
after the first half of the five and one
and uh Costa uh what do you think of the
start so far the chances for the two
players
fantastic match David it's been a
fantastic match so far we saw Rana get
off to an early lead gukesh missing uh
some winning positions there but then he
gets that fourth game win it wasn't
clean it was quite messy but I I think
that might even be a good thing the fact
that he now has this confidence he knows
he can win uh some time scrambles
against Roanoke so I think we were going
to get ourselves a very very close match
as was predicted by the Oracle smarter
chess looks like we're gonna have a
couple uh we're gonna have a second half
now of the five plus one portion the
game uh is just about to get underway
started off his semi-final match down
three games which was uh I think a very
very big surprise
so uh here he's down
sorry did I say ronaker started off his
semi-final down three games
now he's down one
um so it's a little bit less of a
surprise the second time I guess when we
we've already seen it once we've seen
him come back just fine
um but uh the the level of Defense from
Roanoke has been really uh terrifying to
me personally yeah just fantastic
defense with just no time on the clock
just seconds seconds on the clock he's
not only finding reasonable moves he's
finding like strong moves they're seeing
practice honestly they're both playing
Amazing in in the time scrambles but
ironic in particular has been
um very very good on on the defensive
side of things and here we have game
five of the match ronic one point ahead
go cash with the white pieces and I
think this is our first repeat open in
gukesh going for this kind of Berlin
exchange structure once again
yep absolutely right I was thinking the
same thing
um that said roundak played great in
this game that I mean you know in the
game two games ago where they had this
position I didn't personally see any
crack in his play that would have
encouraged me to say hey I'm going back
to this
thing but of course you know Lucas
saw something in there that I that I
didn't see of course
yeah yeah absolutely but okay it's a
little bit different now you just played
D4 he's opening up the the position
um a little counter-intuitive since
you're playing against the two Bishops
but on the other hand when black takes
and then white recaptures you do get
this kind of long-term thing where oh
I'm sorry hold on hold on White's not
going to recapture I'm sorry normally
why would recapture here there's just E5
it's just E5 Dave and just wins okay
wins the piece recapturing might be fine
too you know you get the nice structure
but E5
um that would that would hurt surprising
details surprising details so that makes
it feel like Knight d7's almost the only
move yet we see round neck going in for
a deep think
um so there was obviously
an adjustment he was making there
uh and some other things he was checking
covers the E5 Square I think it makes
sense now I feel like C3 logical move
here for my okay goes Queen to E2
maybe intending Rick to D1 at some point
yeah I mean there were a lot of
interesting moves possible not
necessarily good but from Black's
perspective stuff you have to watch out
for white could have done a general
trade-off on E5 followed by F4
F4 F5 you know just rushing that pawn up
the board
there was also a weird line with D4 D5
so
I understand now the time around I spent
s the Knight the bishop over to H4 very
very limited scope it's gonna have to
really pressure the five square a lot
yeah interesting move or kind of
maneuver by Gucci like provokes F6
brings the bishop to H4 probably gonna
reposition the bishop to a g3 at some
point to Target Black's own dark squared
bishop and just Rook D1 just kind of
building up like you know it's going to
be a quiet game and I expect no pieces
will be traded until there's like 30
seconds left and then we're just gonna
get complete complete Mayhem
okay
fair fair prediction yeah that's my
smarter chess prediction for this game
yeah by the way what do you think
overall the smarter chess prediction
like do you think that there is a
favorite in this match
and uh by how much like would you be
surprised to see your underdog win no I
don't I don't think there's a particular
favorite I think both players are just
monsters and either one of them can win
uh as long as they have a better day
than the other I think it really just
depends on who has the better day who is
in better shape who sees more tactics
who's a little bit looser and faster
with the Mouse
um I think that's the player that and it
could just come down to like one or two
you know it could come down to just one
sequence in one bullet game that decides
you know the next Junior speech has
Champion
um so I feel like sometimes these things
you know not really about like who's the
favorite or who deserves them or
anything like that it's really just
about who happens to be a little bit
luckier at the right moment yeah
yeah if if it is truly that closely
matched
um and given that they won their
semi-finals by similar margins
it does feel like it could be that
evenly matched
um
and uh
I you know I think I speak for most
people in the world cost you when I say
I would want
to somehow be cleverer than smarter
chess when I see someone else make
predictions I always want to have like a
better prediction than them
you might be one of the few people that
doesn't fall into that category but most
people love for someone else to be a
little bit wrong and for you to be a
little bit more right than them
and uh so I I find it mildly infuriating
in general that the smarter chess
predictions tend to be accurate
okay and hold on what what's going on
here this is something something
terrible has happened that's the bishop
on G3 hanging I think he played F3 yeah
without fully anticipating the
consequences of he takes D4 because now
black snags a spawn he can't recapture
it Bishop his hanging Queen is hanging
the queen drops back to F2 now C5 thank
you for the pawn sir takes takes Knight
D1 he was trying to limit that Bishop
that light squared Bishop which is well
intentioned I mean that that's a
dangerous Bishop so he played H3 and he
played F3 and he was trying to be ready
for any F5 or G4 Shenanigans and
unfortunately missed tactical detail
which is something that both of these
players rarely do and and raunak spotted
it
yeah yes and ironic's just a clear Pawn
up but it'll still be tough these
positions are never easy right Black's
King is going to be a little bit exposed
White's Knights are always going to be
jumping around Knight G4 Knight G3
targeting blacks Queen we'll see if
gookesh is as resilient and tricky in
defense as roundock I would suspect he
he won't be quite that's something that
raunak has you know maybe at even a
slightly
uh better level as a practical skill
yeah possible line like Bishop takes A2
here he could grab this Pawn Yeah and
then meet Knight G3 Queen F7
very very divide up five
yeah attacking H6 and D6
yeah two pawns put into the a pawn at
what cost yeah exactly exactly
oh 92. wow ronic hold on he's down two
minutes on the clock here he's not used
to the burden of having a nice position
it's trying to convert in in this match
but like you said this is now going to
be gukesh's turn to kind of defend uh
very very difficult position but
thankfully for him he has a lot of time
on on the clock
well yeah and suddenly we see him like
speeding up right like he answered Queen
F7
which he thought about for a minute
right and he answered with F4 basically
instantaneously like hammering that that
responsibility right you need to really
think about your moves when you have the
advantage
isn't it so sad
all right oh Knight G4 don't blunder
Knight takes H6
it's gonna win the queen no he's not
gonna plunger that that's silly I know I
was talking to chat don't love her
even even Chad's not gonna blunder it
like the guy just played Knight G4
looking straight at age six
okay I was telling myself not to blunder
Knight takes H6 all right Knight comes
back to E3
and oh these Knights are jumping around
now he's looking at that F5 Square he's
really telling him to take A2 though
he's really he's selling it he's like
you got to take something
6 F4 oh but that invites more Knights
into the game yeah I guess F1 right so
this looks chaotic like Knight D5 Queen
E4 Knight F6
because you don't want the black queen
locked away from the King side that's
really dangerous for black
when it goes this way keeping the Rook
open on the D file and yeah Knight takes
F6 is a huge problem for black now it's
looking very good for gookash I mean
he's he's a pawned down but he's got the
initiative and oh eval baller just shot
way up well yeah it takes on F6 he
threats in Knight F6 and black didn't
find a way to stop it
oh he found a way not to lose the
exchange but Queen H4 and now this one
is hanging as well oh Queen H4 super
strong
11 seconds left and it has fallen apart
quickly
and if this were your first time
watching a chess match you would think
having good positions
is really bad in chess
that was it that was it Ronin resigns or
did he flag I didn't see the end but the
position was was dead lost there was no
defense all the threats so gooka she
turns that one around evens up the match
two and a half two and a half each ask
ronic how he likes it not to win a
winning position yeah pretty frustrating
right yeah
really frustrating
um yeah we've got ourselves a full-blown
full-blown match here
yeah
Roundup goes back to C4
somewhere I feel like roundup's not
going to be particularly phased you know
he's played a couple a couple of matches
before I think he knows there's always
going to be swings you got to keep your
energy up you know there's still going
to be a three minute portion one minute
portion a lot of Chess left to be played
yeah we're gonna get a technical game
finally I think Costa I think we're
gonna see Knight C3 Rook C3 Knight D4
yeah this might be the first time we're
seeing like a couple of Peace trades
long again
okay all right we got
we got some trade
yeah we got some trade we might even get
more trades here
David we might get a heavy peace end
game queens and Rooks and pawns this is
why they shouldn't have old people
commentating on a young people's game
I'm like sitting here rooting for an
endgame Coast yeah it's like what what
get rid of this guy what's he doing here
shut up and go home old guy
laughs
Queen C2 may be finally forcing that
trade
yeah no but Knight C3 Bishop H7 it's
risky now look come on these kids
they've been working with like Soviet
coaches right for a while these kids you
know they get visited by people like
gelfend like kramnik you know they come
in they tell them not to play bullet
actually I don't know if we mentioned
this fact on the show David you know but
it's
um I will known about gukesh that he
didn't use engines right until he was a
very very strong player at the request
of his coach
yeah and and we can see how that turned
out for him his analytical skills his
calculation it's pretty good it's pretty
it's really strong when I think of
gookesh and it's it's always hard for me
to evaluate players over a certain level
which is around 2700 I start to really
struggle to
say like their strengths and their
weaknesses because it starts to just all
seem really strong but um when I think
of gukesh the first strength that I
think of is calculation
like I think like oh my goodness
you know in a classical game the depth
to which he's calculating to me is just
wow
foreign
he wants Knight D2 right
yeah
now in Bishop C4 I assume he wants
something like 33. ain't something
terrible Knight G3 Queen C3
but yeah evil bar is not impressed so
Knight G3 Queen C3 yeah getting out of
the attack by hitting the mate there's
no 92 check
and black would just have to drop back
right to defend the pawn
wow but then where did your Pawn go now
White's just would be a pawn up
let's see if um
and Bishop C4 played
ronak calling the bluff
yeah unconvinced I mean well what
options did white have it's not like
he's gonna go Bishop take C4 Bishop
takes C4 and then resign the game that's
probably
not
what wrong if we want
yeah I don't want to speak for these
players but that's probably not what he
would want
um so takes and then it just Bishop F5
poor gukesh admitting his mistake you're
right I didn't have anything I'm sorry
yeah
and can't get can't get one past chronic
see he could have had a technical end
game coaster now he's got a position
where he's down an outside passed Pawn
you know Knight versus Rook pond and a
raging Bishop pair oh
yeah
this is now it feels like a yeah
technically winning position for why you
got this past Apon
but let's say this goes dude like if I
ever had this position as black I would
have been in a hurry to trade off that
dark squared Bishop with my knight right
that's why it was all my brain
could think was that this technical
position was coming because
if you ever give your opponent the
chance to play Bishop B2 I feel like
you're so much worse and of course
Google just understands it at a higher
level like he just knows that he can
allow it I mean obviously he didn't you
know hanging the pawn was a bad thing
but he doesn't have that same fear
that I have about a certain type of
position
yeah
but okay now look at now look at WISE
Bishop how you know how did that work
out for him
not not great in this game maybe a
little fear could have been helpful all
fear of the bishop hair might have been
might have been apropos now he got a
chance to try it's a background but
that's just game oof what exactly
oh man oh God he just thought he he
thought that that round that a pawn that
was not realistic I was not realistic to
think that Robin could just hung the a
pawn oh man oh he just fell for that
hook line and Center yeah oof
wow and then the back rank
man that happened so fast
we had everything covered
it happened so fast I thought maybe
Coast is like showing like an analysis
very she took me a moment to realize
like Google catch is just playing
straight down like mate on the board
oh man Bishops eat six
chat chat giving us the advice you could
call it hook line and stinker it was a
bit of a blunder there that's good
that's what I should just say thank you
thank you
that was a blender on my end um all
right we can all pick up some tricks
today on the chess board and on the mic
we've got opposite Castle Kings again
yes
yeah so again with the Berlin but this
time the first time black has castled uh
queenside hasronic in these positions
um going into
uh yeah just a very very sharp position
and now Bishop H5 ooh this could get
very double-edged very quickly and in
Queen E3 unpinning but also I feel like
black really wants to go G5 in this
position so white 100 has to kind of
fight against that
yeah
and you you can see the subtext of
what's going on in this Clash Coast yet
is last game roundock played great with
kingside castling and F6 a pristine game
and uh gookish made a slip and ronak got
a good position and then lost so this
time around it's like I gotta switch it
up I can't get such a good position I
can't play you know straight into this
position that I knew so well and played
perfectly let me try and get
maybe a bad position before it's too
late put some pressure on go cash
and then get the comeback
exactly but yeah Rana keys back to the
one point lead definitely feeling good
because he was uh he you know gave back
two points
uh
hey well this game again I think it
could go of course any any three ways as
most of these games
I've been
all right now we got the structure we
were we almost talked about previously
where it's like in the long run white
has four pawns against three on the king
side
and can make a past Pawn in the long run
not anytime soon but F4 E5 but for black
with the doubled C pawns this four
versus three is actually pretty
ineffective in the end game and very
very easy to to block for white
so yeah White's kind of long-term
strategy here is the old man approach
trade off all the pieces get into a king
and pawn end game and then you win
because you effectively have an extra
Pawn in the position
yeah we just got a very very fancy A3
move like that's that's some classical
chess and a blitz match
um
one observation I would make here is
that to me the E and D files are so
volatile you know open or half open
that it's not really a throw your pawns
uh Pawn storm you know clashing Pawn
storms kind of position I think there's
going to be some you know fighting for
Central squares like you see with same
side castling
mm-hmm
9c4 Bishop C1 and then B4
oh Knight B6 what a counter
never runs out of ideas or
oh man very interesting but Knight E5
oh Bishop's hanging he's got Knight C6
is he gonna take on C6
of the game
gotta pop on C6 here oh Coast yeah
I was thinking Knight C6 bc6 Queen D3
yeah exactly I'm not even bringing the
second Knight
there's uh
there's got to be someone let me let's
go back quickly because we've got time
let's just see you want to see if we can
if we can figure out if it was good or
bad yeah yeah exactly yeah I know I
think this was
this was it Knight C6 takes
he's got like Queen E2 for example oh
man
that would have been devastating the
king's gonna have to come to D7
and uh
you know then maybe Rook ad1 right there
yeah the attack continues it's certainly
not easy for white but we can see king
the king is running around
yeah
um but we gotta let's get back to the
game here so Bishop D6 Rook D1 played
Rook h e eights and queen F3 oh boy
engine not liking a lot of these it's
such a sharp position I'm imagining
white might be able to take on C6 in
like all these positions and just just
avoiding it an oh E5 he finds that one
though hitting we should beat seven
in general white has always been
intending to answer
well there's no in general to it but
black always had this move Queen E5 for
white to watch out for sometimes the
answer was Knight back to F3
Queen on F3 blocks that but now with E5
The Rook will stop 0.5
man how do you save even like ronic the
magician sidwani I don't know if he can
save this look at this dude B7 is
hanging the bishop is obviously hanging
you got E6 coming
to just totally mate the king all right
C6
yeah at this point if if he doesn't sack
on C6 I mean
it's time
yeah if he takes on D6 black can take
twice on E1 and then take on D4
and it's not and then can you play
Knight C6 at the end there this could be
good yeah as long as maybe it takes here
exactly
it could still be very very good for
white because the queen is going to be
super strong against Black's uh weak
King
so he he does take on these oh we just
got this whole line all right so gookish
knows
Knight C6 on the board Rook takes D6 now
Knight takes D4
so we got queen versus two Rooks
um
still very messy if Knight C4 then Queen
c 3 Bishop F7
it was another angle there's Knight A4
yeah covering covering Bishop C3 Bishop
C3 very much playable especially because
Knight takes Queen takes would be
picking up the Rook due to the check
yeah this still feels extremely nice for
white because
I you know I've heard of the queen is
often better in the middle game against
the two no no you're saying I haven't
heard that come on who Rooks are better
two Rooks are better no it's not true
Dave in the middle game the Queen the
queen can fight especially especially
when the king is open of course I know
that I won't convince Coast yet we've
been arguing about this for a long time
is changing
wisdom is changing everyone can see
magnus's win over Geary
Geary just picks up two Rooks for his
for his Queen and then just loses
immediately it just walks into lost
position
or his win over Napo or Napo traded to
Rooks for a queen in the end game and
then regretted it in the end game well
often when you trade to rooksburg Queen
it tends to move the game a lot closer
to the end game but that's what I'm
saying this is still a middle game
there's a ton of pieces on the board and
then the material is very similar to the
Magnus uh versus nepo game anyway we'll
we'll we'll argue offline later
everybody for now just remember that two
Rooks are better than a queen
and let's watch the action yeah but
let's watch how good cash wins the game
with his queen against the two Rooks
okay so the bishop on B2 can't really be
repositioned you want to play C4 here if
you could because you want to chip away
at Black's King
the factor that's most exciting for
white is the black king position so
Queen G8 to G7 sacking your Bishop you
can also consider looking for a weigh-in
and he just makes room to keep the
bishop with Bishop D4 so that
yeah
so there's no Knight B2 I like the
solution I mean if the bishop gets to D4
and is super solid like on E3 yeah and
and then he just goes back that's a
great sign for whites King
but of course won't be easy to break
through I mean black is now it looks
like Veronica's switched strategies use
first plank for counter play now looks
like he's just trying to build a
fortress here
the Knight on A4 is pretty bad white
definitely has some juice
Bishop F7
hitting the Queen Bishop G6
draw draw
not a ton of good squares for this queen
now he finds he finds a round Queen D2
Queen comes to F4
okay so now if the Knight moves
to like B6 or B2 for example
the bishop can't take it you can go
Queen F4 unpinning the bishop but then
Knight C4 defends the rook and then
Bishop C5 at the end would win for white
that's why he moved the Rook on Nissan
okay
he's got no time to defend this he's
doing his best but Rook D7
I feel like white just has total control
but still C2 is hanging
they each need to improve their Knight
that's the key to the position for both
players right Knights here kind of not
doing much
okay Queen E3 takes on C2
if Queen E6 King B7 yeah yeah I mean the
knights are just activated I like Queen
E6 yeah oh there should be three getting
ready to cut the Rook with Bishop F4
three seconds for Roanoke
F4 does he
oh now the Knight comes in
oh turning on Super Saiyan mode he's not
doing great tonight they're both coming
and now anything could happen and they
heard you happen in this
I heard you look at this but he snags
the H7 Pawn I feel like that's going to
be important a certain point why you can
just start running the H Pawn playing
for the two weaknesses
oh and Roanoke Flags
wow two Rooks are better you guys saw it
here on to the next game uh now that
we've learned so much about Rooks the
match is now tied three and a half three
and a half as close as can be the match
timer we should take a look at every now
and then 15 minutes left in the five and
one portion
so at least two games and probably only
two games left in the 5-1
and Yeah ironic definitely looking a
little disappointed there that's his
first flag of the match the position
still had a ton of fight I mean it's not
like it was it was time to resign just
yet but
um gukesh is looking very very
uh motivated right now and um oh I think
I think Roundup won that game right
wait no I thought ronak flagged did I
did I get that wrong I thought go cash
flanked
no but their score is even now is even
now yeah okay
yeah confirmed confirmed no they got an
even match now okay
and uh yeah Rocky's back to his English
the last time they had this opening
white managed to play D4 D5 and now
black managed to play D5 T4 yeah
structure has changed actually this is
uh
it's very interesting but
ronic again going at the king side yeah
I remember the last game he went like
Bishop C6 at some point and then F4
just completely went after Black's King
side I wonder if he's gonna do something
similar here yeah he takes
and Bishop A3 oh a little more nimso
Style
yeah absolutely just classic you leave
your opponent with a bishop that can't
defend the dark squares and then you
attack the dark squares yeah simple and
straightforward and Lucas just gives the
pawn I love it honestly very quickly
for you know five minute game right I
guess he felt like he had no ways to um
defend it in any way now I mean
technically he had a way to defend it
which was Queen B6 which was super
awkward yeah um and I love I I mean
I love seeing just the you know here's
the pawn let's get everything active I I
love what he did he just gets his Rook
takes on poissons Bishop F5
Queen A5 I mean these two Bishops are
working
David these two Bishops are working he's
got E4 in the position
oh man yeah which doesn't want really
would be for him to play E4 and white to
play D4 right
yeah so I guess a big question is if he
goes rook d8 and white develops the
Knight
would he be satisfied to regain the pawn
on D3 with a little tactic and take on
C5 at the end
yeah Rick did I mean looks like a very
obvious move right just putting pressure
here and then threatening as he said to
take twice and then pick up this guy
um but maybe I don't know I feel like
black should be playing for more it's
like White's King is so open on the
queen side you know
yeah
Ricky it on the board
yeah so the Knight I think has to go to
E2 because Knight F3 E4 is like
maybe I'm missing something but looks
like an obvious blunder
um so Knight E2 but White's thinking a
bit
well I mean playing King A1 is not going
to help you so I've developed the Knight
yeah Knight E2 feels like you just got
to get the pieces out so yeah think
about E4 black would love to play it but
as David mentioned then if white can
respond with D4
hey keep some
keep some defense in the position not so
easy to to break through so ukesh does
take on D3 takes the bishop on C5
exactly the position I was wondering
about Queen E4 yeah immediately just
covering the E4 Square I just didn't
want to allow black to push E4
um gives up the F2 Pawn but yeah I think
Veronica's doing the right thing just
trying to cover as many
light squares as possible not if black
can open up the bishop with E4 it's
going to be very very dangerous or white
it's feeling it's feeling really good
for black Coast yeah I think that uh
gukesh probably evaluated correctly in
going for rook d8 and this apparent
simplification
because the heavy piece ending is
probably winning with the King not
having a b or c Pawn to block the second
rank
um and meanwhile E4 is so devastating
that he can ignore the C6 Pawn the F5
Pawn he can just do anything to try and
open open it up and he counts on the
White Queen just being
stuck yeah Queens are not good block
haters
okay here he just takes on F5 goes for
the end game maybe it could have been
more ambitious you know white skin was
pretty weak but it is
now I feel like it's within range of the
sadhwani unreasonable defense system
yeah just the magic hold
um we'll see I mean
it looks like white has a lot of like
block hating chances but white also has
a lot of weaknesses Rook can come down
hit the a pawn hit the Knight G4 at some
point the C5 move yeah the engine not
liking it possibly because it's a Target
right for for Black's Bishop here from
f8s I was definitely expecting Brook D1
but maybe
maybe he had some hesitation about black
playing G4
G4 is definitely I think a move that
that's gonna happen yeah if white allows
it just if black and win the H5 pawn and
get two connected passers on the king
side that would just be game over so
yeah white I think under no
circumstances can lose this H Pawn
it's awkward for black Rook on F5 is
chiffon G7 still quite passive so
gookish is gonna have to find a way to
activate these pieces
yeah ship f8 played B4 expected
defending the pawn
okay three typical
I want I want to give him an acronym
Costa I want to call it Suds the
sadhwani unreasonable defense system so
you could be like Captain activate suds
that's good I like Suds yeah you just
get into some bad end game and then
you're just like switch it on okay you
know I'm down one or two pawns but it's
not enough shout out to uh Krishna in
the chat who said Suds which I didn't
understand at first but now I get it
yeah
that's awesome
okay Rook F7 I like the Switchback now
he's getting ready maybe Rook B7 Rick D7
dude what do you think about the end
game if the Rooks come off the board
easy draw
easy draw white just kind of blocks
everything yeah unless black plays King
D5 to C4 but like let's say white gets
to play King E4 dead draw
so you're saying it probably just
depends as usual
yeah
well yeah I mean I didn't just give a
vague depends it was based on one very
specific Factor
uh and a lot of end games are decided by
whether or not you know the opponent's
king just immediately walks into a
position or not
now King F5 activating the king
yeah that's very very bad news for white
A3 no it's looking huge for for good
cash especially if he gets E4 and at
some point maybe he could even play it
right now and off for the Rook
um yeah chooses not to but yeah once
this bishop opens up then the Knight is
going to start facing some real problems
this is what was happening Coast yet
like positionally it was like Rook A3
and White's position is completely
Fallen apart but Rook F1 check taking
the bishop on f8 and White's position
may have fallen apart But it includes an
extra minor piece
Rook F1 all right now Bishop B7
improving the bishop Bishop G5 yeah it
looks just totally winning for black now
that he's controlling the E4 Square you
can push E4 at will
and open up all his pieces
this is uh I wonder about a really ugly
move King G5 cost yeah
ooh greedy greedy give me that pawn
it looks really bad sliding into like
the line of the Knight and the Rook all
the tactics he does it too okay does it
yeah
oh it looks very strong because if white
has to play Rook H1 then okay King G5
looks fine once white plays Rook H1
yeah and then black can continue G3 and
Rook F2 and yeah just keep making
progress incremental progress now I
think roddick's really gonna need
this is going to be pretty ridiculous
even for
for the suds yeah I think he forgot to
turn it on this game like C5 didn't seem
like his normal defense
or is it is it just not critical yet for
him is he just like
still waiting maybe maybe they need to
be under a minute as well
right right
so early times six
this was the most time they've ever had
on the clock when going into an end game
yeah in the meantime half minutes each
has he's activated his gukesh automatic
technique mode okay the gats gets the
stupid he's well on his way to
converting oh look at this tactics
leaving the e-pawn hanging because of
Rook E6 with the pen three yeah it also
may be the kind of position where you
just go H5 H4 H3
now I mean these two pawns are are just
massive
yeah
it should be pretty straightforward here
for for black as long as he just doesn't
allow you know some B5 somewhere some
counter play but
you should win I mean these two pawns
are strong Black's pieces are good
yeah E4
G Pawn is hanging the g-pawn is
important yeah g-pawn is way more
important than this Rook holds the Jeep
fantastic exchange it's not even a
sacrifice it's just like okay if you
take you lose that's what happens
so the petite combination
yeah
very good
um Colby nasal
if you want to fully French it
um cuts the night off from basically the
entire universe that the H5 Pawn is in
with Bishop F6 that night
may as well be in a different reality
and here comes the H Pawn
here it comes looking strong why not
white goes on C6 C7 black always has
Rook C3 check at the end right when
you're celebrating
oh I don't think he's celebrating
I think he I think he knows
he knows he's losing the race here just
a classic Pawn race but you only have to
win
by one tempo okay you know what it's
still
not easy five
Rook D5 Rook D5 yeah last one just
promote right yeah I guess it's not that
complicated
that's it ronak resigns giving go cash
the win and I think that's gukesh's
first lead in the match
one point for gukash four and a half
three and a half
and how are we doing on the time looks
like this is most likely going to be the
last game in the five minute portion
yeah barring one of them hanging their
Queen in the first 10 moves which they
don't seem prone to
which even if they did they would then
be within their rights to just run their
time out and just end the five minute
portion
yeah if they're upset but I mean often
you'd be like I need I you know
you want that extra game certainly like
if you were the one who were behind in
the match at that point you might
might want to force another one in but
go cash has definitely come back from
the early
uh deficit
he's hammering away at the Berlin here
he's happy with what he's getting there
and he's got a one point lead
yeah Veronica's gonna need to win this
game to equalize the score going into
the three minute portion and it got to
be disappointing from I mean the
momentum 100 on gukesh's side now he he
lost two of the first three games and
and since then of course he's uh he
scored several wins um to now take uh
one point lead so Veronica's gonna have
to
uh adjust something he can't just rely
on the the defensive skills anymore
wow the depth of this position
definitely beyond me
um
they're playing very interesting moves
that I can't assess here the a pawn
running looked really strong but C4 was
a huge surprise from White
uh to me at least right so
um yeah very very rich positions big
move but right now he's starting C5 of
course he couldn't do a last move
because the
like hit the Knight with A4 but
C5 definitely a huge threat and uh Kate
Roanoke stops it with his own C5 push
inviting D5 which then allow him to drop
the bishop back to F7 yeah I mean D5
also seems like potentially
an accomplishment for white
um
okay now we'll get like H3 this should
Bishop H5 and then the big question
can white ever go G4
yeah I would definitely expect H3 maybe
Knight F1 now especially after his last
move Rook to E1 Then followed by Knight
G3 and
going after these kingside light squares
yeah
rookie eight I think ronic is not uh
not panicking yet Knight F1
maybe the Knight should go three instead
of G3 because of the bishop on H4
absolutely right absolutely right
like go cash is a very classical
approach she's just finding like normal
maneuvers
proving his pieces
and yeah he follow he goes for a lot of
the same plans like bringing the Knight
to F5 and he's gonna start maybe pushing
on the king side I think maybe he'll
play Knight D2 next I like that he just
rushed the Knight to F5 said look if you
take this piece your light squares are
bad so I don't need H3 and G4 and all
that you just keep improving all his
pieces now improve that Knight which
gives some hope to the bishop on H4 as
well
yeah 92 Bishop drops back
now the question can we see this uh
peace and balance right we got the two
Bishops pharonic and two knights in the
bishop for gookesh yeah
all right should black play any pawn
breaks at B5 and F5 or should black sit
tight
yeah I don't know these positions are
always uh always so tough I'm not really
clear like what white is doing like what
does white really want if you give white
10 moves you know yeah are you going G4
H4 on the king side or are you playing
on the queen side I think you would go
on the queen side that definitely feels
safer to me
okay he allows Knight F4 which I feel
like is not doesn't seem ideal wow this
Rook on B6 seems like a very clever idea
yeah I love this Rook on B6 I love the
Knight on F4 too because you can't
really Chase it away G3 got Knight H3
check yeah but like almost everybody
loves the Knight on F4 right but like
this Rook A6 to B6 that that's clever I
didn't see that coming
yeah not everyone loves the rickon on B4
yeah weird wandering Rook but like with
no open files right
he's found a reasonably large space for
The Rook to not get trapped by minor
pieces and pawns the A4 Pawn helps him
put some pressure on B2
it's nice very nice exactly sometimes
you got to make your own files
there are no open lines in the position
Now The Rook is is putting pressure
Rook C1 he could double on the not open
B file Rook A6 Rook B6
oh man and why not and why not
yeah closed files were made to be
doubled on
that's what Rooks are for
eign
I feel like he wants to he's just not
sure if it's like objectively good but
he wants to yeah
yeah it definitely feels like black is
the one that's kind of in charge here
yeah somehow white feels on the back
foot even though I approved of
everything white didn't again here it
was Rook B6 wrong Brook
the wrong Rook problem
foreign
[Music]
G3 drops back you didn't want Knight H3
there yeah Knight H3 Knight F5 right so
he would just be yeah some other route
so
he brings it back just in time to
challenge White's Knight on F5 exactly
maybe G4 I'm for G4 I think
I noticed your chest.com ratings are
inching towards each other
yeah well that yeah the offer happens of
course in these super
super tight matches
yeah geocache may now be rated 3000 for
the first time in his life if he hasn't
played a lot of online Blitz like
you know that's kind of the only place
where you can get that experience
I think he has I feel like he hit it in
his last match against pranav but I'm
not I'm not sure
okay they traded off the knights now
black Switching gears and look at this
David he played F5 and then Rook on B6
is going to switch over to H6 and then
Queen H5 is Gonna Come
what a rock principle of two weaknesses
he can alternate between H2 and B2 okay
Google is tired of the weakness on B2
let's try it but now I feel like do you
go A3 here
classic example yeah you
you take push or stay
I mean White's not really threatening to
do anything I think like ba4 and B4
don't look good to me so I feel like
black has control of the tension
which gives them a lot of latitude to do
whatever they want maybe Queen H5 which
bring the queen
yeah
is that a brick H6
light Square Bishop I feel like is going
to be very strong peace here for black
in just a bit
yeah the moment white played G2 to G3
that Bishop became really dangerous
Bishop like perks out like oh
did someone call for me yeah oh
I'm ready did someone say we're going to
the park are we going to the park
yeah let me add him let me out okay A3
he spent a lot of time on that decision
that was
so far at the bottom of my list that I
didn't expect it I mean I I considered
it yet wow I mean get the move it's like
it's like a long-term weakness right
this A2 Pawn
um but really really long term yeah very
much so and you kind of give up the
tension right so you could have you
could have left that tension so he goes
to Rick H6 he's committing to the king
side
there should be three allowing F4
they say that like 50 move Grand plans
are gone but A3 is kind of like uh you
know in 50 moves I'm gonna attack the A2
Pawn right yeah absolutely and Rook G6
back yeah something was missed there I
feel like F4 looked very strong to me
but I don't know
um
decides to take on F5 Bishop F5
oh G4
to set up breaking up again so F3 would
be hanging here still if we went 94.
yeah there's no 94 yet
yeah no tactic there to justify it
you're gonna have to be careful of the
pin alongside still got some work to do
it might make sense to tuck that Bishop
on G3 but he goes to G1
so the bishop F2 Bishop takes G4 might
have been yeah what gave him pause
so they're going to go slower way maybe
H3 Bishop H2
on Route 2 setting up all his pieces on
good squares Knight E4 Etc
36 seconds for Ronald who just played
Bishop H4
looking to open up the Bishop's Rook F1
now B6 very simple just defending the
pawn cannot there's no Knight E4 here
because Bishop takes G4 so watch out
this tactics are Rooks T1 we see
defending the Rook yeah I was expecting
Bishop G5 if he played Rook C1 but
instead he lashes out
H5 the onslaught continues
yeah
now Queen a queen queen you take on E5
but I don't think you want I was gonna
ask you like is this Pawn like available
I I think yeah that's oof opening up too
many lines
F4 and now wild tactics oh the Bishops
are coming in
yeah not looking good for whites
could he play fe5 and give up one Brook
put the pawn in E6
5 maybe 40 seconds for gookestra to make
a decision yeah furuchi one you gotta go
yeah deal with ef4 here I think
Queen H4 and he's not hanging anything
somehow oh but there's um there's Bishop
G2 at the end I think you could have
taken
oh wow maybe not I don't know maybe so
now I guess the bishop T5
it's doing something
11 seconds for for Rana he's got a great
chance here White's King on H1 is just
in so much trouble on the light squares
it just doesn't feel
and the Rooks are struggling the Rooks
are struggling to play around the bishop
pair as well
man look at this Rook on H7 this is The
Rook that went from A6 to B6 to B4 and
back now on H7 Rook E3 five seconds for
runic
find a way to trick him here
oh my goodness time's ticking down the
two Bishops are just why I can't yeah I
mean it seems like he has to oh if he
goes rookie four there's Bishop D2 if he
goes here there's
but he had no time what
you know oh it takes another piece just
trying to get moves off and that's it
loses round knock has
done it he has equalized the match uh as
he goes into the break including the
five and one portion that was stupendous
um I imagine that the eval bar which I
am not watching actually today coaster I
imagine it was yo-yoing some because the
position looked crazy but our sort of
human instinct that the bishop pair was
a problem and was covering too many
squares uh it's just a matter of
personally decided yeah he won that game
absolutely
I mean now he's tied it up that's the
end of the five minute portion
all right and uh folks as we take a
short break uh first we want to uh tell
you about
the summer chess camps so attention to
all chess kits all chess parents we're
introducing new summer chess camps by
chess kid and Magnus chess Academy
inspired by the legendary Magnus Carlson
these online camps are designed to make
chess an absolute Blast for young chess
players from beginners all the way up to
Rising Grand Masters
camps are led by top-notch coaches from
the Magnus chess Academy who will unlock
your kids full chess potential with
lessons strategies tactics and of course
lots of fun you can sign up for just one
week or you can sign up for all 11 weeks
enrolled now at go dot chesskid.com camp
or use xlam Camp here in the twitch chat
if you cannot use twitch chat someone
will use it for you X Glam Camp the
summer chess camps where Champions are
made and lifelong memories are created
I would love to go to a chess camp cost
yeah it's been a while
yeah with Magnus especially that would
be fun that would be tons of fun yeah
I'm with you there yeah all right folks
stick around we'll have the three one
portion of the finals between gookesh
and round next adwani starting in just a
couple minutes
thank you
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
did you know you can add Emoji to your
online games and Analysis boards simply
click on the Emoji palette icon select
your emoji and left click on the board
you can choose from a host of notations
animations emoticons and even your
favorite chess personalities
emoticons it will fade away after a few
seconds
however notations and special animations
remain on the board until they are
cleared to clear them simply left click
on the Emoji or hit the clear all button
at the bottom of the palette
have fun try them all on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
and here folks we see Roanoke said wani
who had an incredible win in the last
game of the five and one portion just
now against goo cash he gets through the
slowest time control where you might
think that the classically higher rated
gukesh would have the greatest chances
to get through it with an even score and
if we look back at his previous
performance in the jscc we've got his
finals match against nihal sarin here
the scores from that one from 2021 and
you can see kosia and everybody that he
was down one point
in the 5-1 section against me how
managed to keep it close through the 5-1
and the 3-1 things got away from him in
bullet but here today
you might think that bullet would be
roundex best time control uh with the
experience he has in this and with
gookesh being more of a classical player
whereas nihal sarin more of a blitz and
bullet uh player himself so probably a
pretty good start to the match so far
for round neck your thoughts yeah it
definitely seems like not a surprise
that the five minute portion was close I
think smarter chess actually nailed the
exact score I think he was saying four
and a half four and a half which is just
weird
so upsetting on the DOT
yeah but uh yeah I feel like this is
definitely gonna be decided in the blood
portion uh both these guys are super
fast but they seem very very evenly
matched in um these kind of longer Blitz
Games as we'll call them yeah and um
here we go the three minute portion is
underway ronak back to the English looks
like this is a weapon he kind of wanted
to use in today's match he's been
playing this quite a bit with white
yeah yeah very very consistently going
to this one here I look closely I really
wanted to say that smarter chess's
predictions
were not that smart you know something
like that and I've got a better
prediction and everything
um but it seems like they're very very
evenly matched
um
and then D5 Lucas just fighting in the
center inviting lots of trades on the D5
square and technically this is like a
pawn sack but I think this point is cd5
he's gonna have Knight D4 and a thematic
move hitting Knight D3 check and then
Knight takes D5 you can win back the
pawn and Bishop takes D5 the Knight B4
as well looks annoying for white hitting
both of these things here too right
Bishop E4 Queen E7 Queen E2 Knight C2
would maybe be
the full tactical justification for
black there
um
so yeah maybe maybe opening Theory for
him given uh
given how fast gukesh trotted out this
line he had you know the full three
minutes left
yeah definitely uh sack this Pawn very
very confidently now Ronan goes D3 yeah
I think you just give the pawn back
you'd not want to allow Knight D3 check
being all up in White's position Bishop
F5 E3 you know guess is thinking
it's like you can just take back maybe
he wants to throw in Bishop F5 anyway no
a third move Bishop E7
just developing
says that d-pawn's not going anywhere
he's just letting white defend the pawn
if he wants Knight C3 Knight F4
questions does not care well I mean he
can always go Bishop F5 right and still
get a pawn back although the D5 Pawn is
worth a lot more than the D3 Pawn
generally I mean you would think but I
guess maybe a black maybe black can set
up outposts like Bishop F5
castles Bishop D3 and then C4 and Knight
C2
yeah this is possible
three rookie one
C4 and ugh
double edged yeah the D5 Pawn is strong
but so is Black's that was Knight C2
yeah exactly
yeah very annoying
yeah hey well he's thinking quite a
while on it though I mean that was
40 seconds in a three minute game is
like
40 minutes in a classical game
yeah we'll see how they adjust to the
three minute portion so far no one's
going down too low gukash definitely a
bit lower on the clock is we got some
trades and now I like White's position
quite a bit he's got the structure Okay
just grab the pawn grab the second Pawn
but this is very messy now Knight takes
E3 E3 is hanging
hmm
yeah
I know these two Bishops though as long
as White's a phone remains on the board
it's always going to be a potential
source of danger for black
yeah
there's that a pawn he doesn't even take
C5
yeah I was gonna say Black's gonna need
some very serious counter play on the
king side there's no way long term that
you're defending
with passive defense
against uh Against The Rook Pawn so you
have to go after White's light squares
oh 92 what a finesse yeah good cash
doesn't take back throws in the check
takes the bishop with check
it's everything with tempo
now
now Knight D4 covering the C5 Pawn for
the moment while pressuring F3 and when
The Rook comes to E8 White's gonna have
soft spots at E3 and E2 now
yeah
looks kind of uncomfortable for white so
I'm not yeah not surprised by Rook F2
covering Rook B2 check
oh now H5 wow he's just throwing it all
at him
he didn't even bother playing Rook B3
because he knew the pressure was enough
that white was about to trade on D4
so he's throwing the H Pawn leaving the
Rooks connected as his best way to
defend
against the A5 Pawn
now D3 putting a lot of hopes in this
d-pawn so both sides have passed spawns
but I feel like for me the main thing is
that White's King is definitely it
definitely feels a lot weaker here now
that means White's pieces are gonna have
to spend more time and Care defending
the king whereas black can just kind of
focus on activity Rook d8 Rook 8 now
good enough
and draw the game immediately oh it
takes looks like
yeah they just they just trade okay I
think draw is going to be agreed here
yeah they don't even they don't even
make another move draw offered and
agreed
a pretty clean game actually that was
one I think that was one of the less
Messier games
yeah well it's just that they're getting
into these time scrabbles you know I
mean it's a question of the difficulty
level right as well as yeah time
scrambles and complexity how many pieces
are on the board I don't know exactly
how the soul the whole you know accuracy
thing works but I would guess that you
know the scent upon loss per move that
game the number of mistakes was
basically non-existent
very very high level game and um okay
looks like
see Gucci switched it up different luck
giving us a different look you can
definitely
swing with E4 and D4
a little bit more primarily of an E4
player but no problem switching up
to this kind of position uh and he plays
these positions with white and black
these ones here oh look at this G4 just
immediately going for the attack he's
down a pawn but he's got a lot of
long-term compensation now he's kind of
showing what he wants to do maybe H4
somewhere G5
start opening up Black's King and
looking for for play yeah I think you
need to be pretty quick as white because
Black's gonna play C5 and the position
will not stand still so
absolutely G5 on the board
that looks like a strong move to me
yeah
really nice thing for googash to be able
to play this fast right to be able to
play
to be able to play the entire opening
half the middle game in 15 seconds yeah
hmm
ain't G5 wait looks like something
something was missed there what was
missed
it looks like maybe it would have been
better
uh to come in to come in with Knight D6
Knight D6 okay okay
well
yes you could just go into that spot
apparently yeah it was very strong it's
always hard you know I just jump in with
the Knight like Knight D6 but
right black black takes it and and then
what are we doing
yeah I think it was all about the the
dark skirts here but this feels very
logical Knight G5 H4 he wants H5 and now
Queen C4 probably looking to swing the
queen over to either H4 or T4 at some
point
might end up regretting D3 because
basically until the White Queen gets to
the king side there's not a mating
attack but once you give the queen away
to get to the king side
then you're basically guaranteed to be
mated
okay he wants to take on D2 and take on
G5 in case of H5 look at this Knight B3
but white could maybe play H5 Knight
takes d2h takes G6 you know just don't
recapture on D2
the game I think I feel like he's just
mentally he's just sacrificed his entire
Queen side this side of the board just
doesn't exist for dukesh right now well
it's all about the king's side it's also
about one or two captures away from
literally not existing like he won't
have a piece on the a through D files
yeah
he just ignores it HG he's like what's
happening over there I don't see it yeah
that's what I was suggesting this is the
board
amazing
yeah look at this
so if Black Goes Knight F3 check the
Knight back to F3 and you've got the
queen coming to G6 if black plays F
takes G there's Queen E6
um just looks like
a meeting is out of threats
and if black does nothing then G7 Rook
E8 H7 forcing him to take the G pawn and
96. with me brutal attack eval Bar says
equal it says black as a way out
oh yeah good luck yeah exactly you want
to bet on whether or not ronak finds
three only moves here
to not be mated
I'm gonna say I'm I'm gonna predict
gukesh takes this one it just looks like
the King's game made it yeah
there's literally no way
there's literally no way I mean we could
try to find it
anybody in chat think they can find the
defense for black these takes F5
uh ronic definitely thinks oh yeah I
take it back he found it all he found it
I mean
either our eval Bart is broken or ironic
as we've said is a genius
yeah both are good dude F5 look at this
yeah look at what he's doing
yeah he preserved the pawns because
they're the only thing keeping White's
Queen angry angry Queen away from his
King
and I gotta remember gukash sacrificed a
piece remember he let black take Knight
takes the bishop on D2 and then he
didn't recapture he just went HG letting
black just keep the free piece traded
with the check so now he has to find
something impossible to prove that he is
not losing here down a piece and three
past Pawns
so it looks very dangerous I think one
issue is like rookie six there's Bishop
C8 in the position it's gonna be a
problem okay eval Bar says this is
completely ridiculous but I think that's
a problem all right to me it looked
dangerous so 95 D2
throws the distracting Pawn
oh boy it's actually six I don't know
still looks super dangerous for black
you have H7 G7 oh Knight F7 threading
getting ready to give H7 7h8
yeah it looks super tricky to defend he
could trade the queen here
what Rook takes a seven
leaving everything hanging to go H7 h8
yeah yeah no no it makes it makes
perfect sense but I feel like the king
is escaping it just goes to G6 the black
king yeah he has check and then King
goes to G6 and everything hangs White's
Queen is hanging he can just oh Queen G4
right
oh my God what a mess
what a mess Brooke takes it that move is
is either 20 seconds double X glamor
double question look at this look at
this right he he doesn't he believes him
yeah now however you take on B7 which is
hanging a million times there's Rook G6
ooh
a big problems for good cash he's got
less than 10 seconds C1 pieces are being
captured really fast C1 how does he
defend
there's no King E2
yeah first he throws one last ditch
effort and then the knights get back
chronic takes it
so I would say that's what it looks like
when two players play a brilliant game
at the same time amazing game what a
game
oh
holy moly
as well as as well as in end games I was
extreme sadwani was it
the the unrealistic defense system
unrealistic defense system unreal
defense system man
holy smokes
wow
game of the match so far right there
unbelievable
Wow it looked like he was made in four
moves or you know maybe white would see
a way to win a rook and not mate him but
take the Rook but
and we're on to the next game
that means that Roanoke he's back to his
first lead since the beginning of the
match but now he's got one point and uh
yeah he's feeling it again he's like I
realize you know he's like I gotta stop
getting into these winning positions
they're not working for me it's losing
positions
that's the key where I'm scoring yeah
yeah
I mean do you do you feel good about
having your opponent played like you
know Queen on G4 Pawn on G6 pawn and H6
or do you feel lucky I
seems like he just thinks like yeah I I
I I can play this position a lot of
times in in these matches it's like if
you win a game you're kind of not
supposed to it's it can be quite tilting
for the opponent right because it's like
oh man that was not your point to take
but that is a point he's Gonna Keep
and um wait what's going on here hold on
Gucci is about to
snag this Pawn on D4 and look
very comfortable Upon A D5 was sacked so
yeah he's he's comfortable but it's just
getting back what was his
you can also play the move B5
um you could have played it with or
without taking on D4
and you know because she's just unfazed
he's lost a lot of positions like where
he was winning or should have won but
yeah this game again doing extremely
well with black
you know he's just like he's focused
yeah
yeah I've never looked up to check their
cameras and seen any expression other
than what I would call concentration
yeah
these kids are well trained
you got to keep the focus as soon as you
start you know worrying about the
previous games that's when you it's when
you can go on a very bad run see I just
got to focus on the next game forget
about it realize still a very long match
to go you're only down one point
very very small margin
oh by the way little Horizon right here
little thing about the bishop pair if
you if you click back just one move I
mean it's on the board that black can
play Knight F3 check at any point if
they really want to get crazy about
valuing Bishops right
and uh you know notable that he's not
he's not choosing to do that
yeah it feels like ronic has been the
one with the two Bishops and um most of
these games kind of interesting
stylistic uh difference
to win a Pawn on C4
if white takes
he's probably taking back with the
bishop forcing Rook E2
at Rook C2 he's got some 92 ideas he
goes 92 rookie two does that work Queen
D1 Rook D1 Bishop E2 wait hold on hold
on so rookie one white plays you can
play moves if you want because this 92
variation is a difficult one
yeah yeah I just wasn't following where
you're going I mean 90s there's also
Rick C2 I think is very
Oliver take on D4 that wouldn't be good
okay so what did you want 92 well he's
now played a different move he did not
take on B5
um but yeah I was thinking 92 rookie two
and then Queen D1
rookie one takes everything Bishop takes
E2 if Bishop G7 Bishop D1 and if Knight
E2 Bishop B2 and I just wanted to make
sure that I'd counted right the black
was ahead there
so that's why he didn't take on B5
it was back 92 instead
so it says exact sort of sacked upon I
think
sound C4 yeah Bishop G7 King G7 Rook C1
now Queen D4
so good picking up an extra Pawn here
big time Advantage as well
yeah shows uh ironic not feeling
comfortable with the position 20 seconds
was a very powerful move B5 was really
important yeah but this is a perfect
position for Suds ghost yeah yeah time
to defend it's like this is like the
kind of position where you where you
never win against Roanoke
whoa cv3 we got tactics in the air is he
doing it all on purpose what is
happening
what is he doing
the piece
playing Queen
I'm not sure I get it I sort of like the
defense Rook C7 to A7 it seems insane
but
is a genius huh he's just gonna leave
the pawn on A2
maybe bring the Rook over
bumpy things black is just completely
winning here which is honestly shocking
to me
the computer says Black's winning
completely winning so this was not he
didn't hang a piece he somehow evaluated
that this was a good way to hang a piece
this is a straight up peace sacrifice
yeah absolutely so it's now Queen B1
looks kind of forced no he's got some
other angle to go geez Louise Rook D2
Queen covers Rook F2
c what does he have here yeah it's
surprising that it's so
seems very concrete now maybe Queens
think it would be okay Queen B1 and then
Rook D1 right Rook D1 yeah
how did he evaluate that holy moly now
he can literally just Queen in this
position
there's nothing left
but yeah because yeah that's
okay questions I have for go cash
like how on Earth did you like I don't
know I saw it that's gonna be the answer
right like I don't know yeah yeah no
question number one yeah how how
confident were you about that uh
that PSEC
wow now Queen D1 just trading off the
Queens that's gonna be game
holy moly you could trade the queen and
take the a Pawn off the board that's
where the comeback starts kosia no no
it's four versus three
it was over it was over
if you say so yeah I know even ronic was
not saving that
and he just resigns maybe he wants more
more games in the three minute portion
but he wants more games what a game by
Gucci oh my God yeah
yeah I definitely haven't figured out
when and why ronak plays games on
further versus like moves on to the next
game
I'm sure with the experience he has in
the jscc
he has some kind of like thoughts or
ideas about it but you may remember
there was an early game that he
literally played out to Checkmate in
game
I think the first game that go catch won
game four maybe right
um and it was something where he was
down at queen and a bishop and just
moving his King around in a circle right
and there's other games where
like that one
where if he wanted to prolong things he
could
um
so I wonder what the what a system is
yeah I guess he just I don't know maybe
he just didn't want to continue that
game anymore
that's interesting it definitely is
different that he played on all the way
to mate in the five minute portion and
then yeah it just kind of resigns
um the end game
yeah and the game he played out to mate
by the way he wasn't trying to kill the
clock because he didn't use the 15 or 20
seconds he had he played very very
quickly but played out all the moves
Maybe
maybe sometimes he's like picking his
opening for the next game so he sort of
manages to
split his mind and his hand and his hand
just keeps doing stuff with the Mouse
and his brain is processing some other
task or something I don't know
yeah yeah so the king's gonna be on E2
but as long as the Rook can get on the
other side of it that's not any big news
here yeah I'm trying to like process
this
position black has this uh Bishop on B2
that was defended by the queen via x-ray
now the queen sitting the bishop on C4
um
this looks very unpleasant for black
just first glance with the opposite
color of Bishops in the middle game vice
Bishop on C4 potentially very strong
I mean there's basically one little
detail we need to mention and then and
then chat will understand what's
unpleasant Knight C6 Rook to D7 oops
light squares right yeah so that's the
terror of this position is that
it's not just that lightsward Bishops
favor the king side attack but if the
Knight can't get off of B8 because of
the weakness of D7
okay we need seven here and now I love
this position for white you got Queen D3
in the position at any moment yeah
threatening the mates which uh product
has seen since he was two years old and
dominating yeah then the Black Goes H5
you just take it
oh I can't stop you from loosening the
light squares
night before
C6 yeah threatening the fork
just A3 I love it
not so fast tough guy
yeah A3
yeah yeah still under control here for
white that said if black could somehow
trade pieces like get rook d8 in I think
I think B4 feels like the kind of
um the kind of trick you know where
Round Rock comes up with juice all the
time I would love to know their recipe
like where they find the little stuff
all the time like B4 H5 B takes A3 hg6
fg6 you just say sure you can go Queen
G6 Queen G7 but now I have that a pawn
and somehow it's not always easy
as well kind of for white sneaking in on
the diagonal H5 David you called Rook H5
and yeah I'm sure around I saw it he's
delaying White playing H5 he's saying
this holds my light squares for one or
two more moves yeah
factjust.com saying uh saying brilliant
but I think that was a very intentional
Pawn sack
chess.com called H5 brilliant or Rook H5
brilliant Rook takes H5 okay I think
they've got it backwards this time with
all dude and disrespect but I think H5
the genius he sacked the pawn he's got
opposite colored Bishops he avoided H5
for one or two moves created one Rook
time for Rook D7 with the other Rook I
mean this is just
the computer can't tell how good it is
it's it's still very difficult for black
though because G6 was hanging there and
now H5 I mean I feel like white has too
many pieces for black to be really
comfortable here right King is very weak
now we got Queen C2 coming back uh
now she's back
it does still look lost after H5 you
know
but it still seemed brilliant to me as a
person I was like wow great idea oh it
was very it was very creative idea
absolutely yeah
Rick D5 coming in with the Rook
it comes to E6 Bishop F5 I feel like
calls for itself
yeah I mean
smudger Glory if you said that I didn't
see a move you're probably right and
you're welcome to say it that's totally
fair game
all right Knight D4 I don't think he
wants the Knight to F5 so what's the
plan on Bishop takes all right just
trades it takes back but now we have no
more opposite color Bishops we just have
pure Bishop versus Knights wax King
still very very open
yeah we have a Fisher end game if black
can get to it but
you would sort of expect this King to go
down in a moment
yeah just looks so busted for black he
just needs to coordinate like his pieces
here I don't love this pen right uh The
Rook I know he's got to get like the
queen in somehow but there's a Queenie
one check in the position gotta be
careful
against Queen F3 there's Queen E1 to B1
I wanted to adjust the queen so I can go
Rook G5 and not have the queen trade
hanging at the same time as the Rook
right like Rook G5 King H6 or something
and then you have to
have something brilliant ready
but okay he finds the wave they've got
seconds left to figure this out now it's
an absolute mess
rookie five coming if King T8 so he has
to cover with something rookie seven
right but Queen E7 and that's why he'll
go like Queen D2 and his Queen's
covering E1 and The Rook brick C5 back
to the cell phone he's got rich Knight
D7 Rook C8 would have been evil and that
move just hangs a rook I think that uh
Rook takes the queen is pin Queen B4 ab4
gookash wins a nice game and hold on
David yeah
he's got another lead
he does have the lead he's got another
lead here it's hard to keep track of who
has the lead because it's been little
bursts of like two move streaks and
sometimes I'm not sure who's who's ahead
by one
yeah yeah they've just been trading the
lead back and forth
wow I think that was it
fantastic game from gookesh also for a
second here I didn't know who had white
because
ronak has been playing the Berlin right
and now gukash is playing the Berlin
so roundak gave C4 a rest for one game
here oh because he had one terrible game
with C4 he had one game just now that
went really badly around like
um got basically a bad position out of
the opening
with Wayne
yeah it usually makes sense to switch it
up when things don't go your way
um this is very solid for for ronic and
still one point game plenty of match to
go they've got uh 30 minutes left in the
three plus one portion they're gonna
have another 30 minutes of the bullet so
tons of chess
hitting his stride absolutely I feel
like gukash has been very very calm this
whole match very level-headed
yeah
incredible oh what's happening here
Knight takes G2
things are dancing and it's crazy what's
ronic doing
we gotta check the camps
that looks like the correct night to
take with
all right does not look happy
okay
he's not sure exactly what he planned
here yeah he plays grabbing H5 threaten
is made in one
yeah might as well right might as well
but G6 Queen comes in oh we have this
902 is super annoying Brook on E1 still
hanging
full broke on anyone's hanging Bishop G5
is probably White's idea it doesn't
really look like it's enough there's
also a knight H5 right Knight E1 maybe
Knight H5 is a problem
oh
can't take the Rook just yet
oh wow okay and Bishop E5 doesn't help
with that I'd been thinking of like
Bishop takes E5
but it doesn't it doesn't help with that
problem at all LH just recaptures and
the mates are are still there the tricky
spot for for good cash I mean you gotta
feel like black has a move here but what
what's it do the queen F6
and what does he want on Knight h
Ive here
tell me it's not Queen h8 yeah tell me
it's a queen bro
let's fake resilient defense
I played it
then I can threaten the Knight because
the queen covers H7 as well as G7
I really want to see that H5 Queen hn on
the board okay Bishop G5
but that allows us why why Black's
Knight is Pian keto near White's game
between G7 now after the in-game trade
why we'll have a chance to save The Rook
but they're still there's Bishop E5 in
the position followed by Knight F3 check
yeah and you're still down to pawn white
so you're supposed to be proving
something not like
flailing but yeah you can't um what
choice does he have right Bishop H4
Queen will hang on H6
what's it do
yeah immediately this is still a threat
takes a knight F3
yeah and rookie two Bishop takes E5 yeah
I don't see a good move for Roundup
right here
and he just told me yeah he doesn't see
one either
nope
rookie two maybe even Bishop H3 playable
well Bishop E5 here is good right
actually I'm not sure about Knight of
Threes there's King takes G2 King taking
the Knight but
F6 forcing the end game and yeah just
healthy extra Pawn here for black
yeah very healthy very nice Bishop pair
as well Bishop pair two yeah
there's something
strange and magical
about the Berlin defense coaster have
you ever played it
um not much no really really no have you
yeah
and the thing about playing the Berlin
defense is like once you play it it's
like
you've said I have no intention of ever
beating you my friend
all I'm claiming is that you are going
to be extremely frustrated
and then before you know it you're
winning
as black that's what happens
yeah
you should try it sometime I think
you'll do very well
yeah I mean I I could be into it I could
get into it
I don't hate it yeah
is there Knight D4 by the way Bishop D7
no
or you'd have to put the bishop on like
C8 or something to set it up so instead
G5 G4 the positional approach
yeah he's just advancing his King side
pawns I mean looks very very comfy for
black
G4 H4
okay so the line that I was calculating
was G4 Knight H5 King H6
but the White Knight can go to F6 and it
doesn't work so
so instead he plays he gives up the
bishop here
not what he desired I I bet you that
when googesh played G5 he wasn't hoping
for this
it simplifies it down a bit but still
looks extremely comfortable for blacks
very healthy pun he's got the e-file now
you can just keep marching his pawns
forward
rookie one not possible by the way
because Knight F3 check
um
yeah or to play this is white I feel
it's okay ronic just needs to defend
just play a few defensive moves you know
bring the king to F4
that's the defender or not
now he gets Ricky one in
yeah
unfortunate necessity just because there
weren't any other Moves In general the
Rook ending has the highest drawing
chances here compared to the night
ending or the same color Bishop ending
or a knight versus Bishop ending so
rookie one was slightly undesirable but
just had to had to be done so
it brings a knight back yeah I think
he's going to want to push the F Pawn
soon
on F3
trading off the pawns oh but letting
blacks
King f294 King E2 Knight G3 so yes let
the king go all the way in and that's
the end oh yeah this is one he just
resides yeah
it's it's understood so yeah again okay
not like premature resignation exactly
but like he could have played on more if
you wanted to right
yeah
he knows he probably knows he's down two
games right there
um so he just saves time on the on the
match clock and uh we'll be back with
the second half of this three-in-one
portion after a very quick break for
both players
so see you then
[Music]
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
oh
use gifts from the biggest chess stars
on all of your favorite platforms
just search chess.com and your favorite
chess star on Discord Twitter WhatsApp
and more to find hundreds of gifts from
chess.com's biggest broadcasts and
events Hikaru Magnus botes Hess and even
me Danny try it today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to the junior
speed chess championships
final match who cash versus Round Rock
sadwani
fifteen thousand dollars in prizes and a
spot in the main speed chess
championships we have quite a match on
our hands and uh right now yukash taking
a two-point lead here in the three and
one portion after an even five and one
portion post did you feel like he is
pulling ahead a little bit or it's just
one of the little back and forths
yeah David I really feel like the tide
of the match has shifted in gukesh's
favor just seems like playing a little
bit cleaner he's converting a little bit
smoother and now he has his first two
point lead ever we know we start he
started off with uh half out of three
now he's leading by two definitely looks
like he's feeling very very confident
right now of course he's just looking
his normal Focus self it doesn't matter
if he's leading it doesn't matter if
he's losing he's just gonna keep a
straight face until the end of the match
and um here he goes back to D4 and ronic
switching it up with a classic uh King's
Indian you know me I'm a big fan of this
choice in fact chronic is playing this
quite um quite a trendy approach with
this early H6 and B6 moves very very
flexible setup here from him
yeah
um you know he won that absolutely crazy
game The Last Time gookesh played D4
um and yet this time he chooses to
switch gears
um
and I guess B6 is not necessarily
associated with putting the bishop on B7
it's just blockading the a3b4 C5
diagonal where white needs Pawn breaks
to make progress
exactly yeah we have like a very classic
Kings Indian structure here though
interestingly gukash spent a couple
extra Tempe right playing rookie one
Bishop F1 Bishop G2 and uh definitely to
me uh as a very biased Kings Indian
player it looks like black is a good
position he's got in his F5 break-in now
he has all these ideas of f4 and E4 or
it's very very sharp Knight H4 fighting
back but yeah I like this for for ronik
so far
yeah I mean the big move for white would
be F4 in general to keep that pawn Duo
from expanding however it wants in the
future
um
I feel like gukesh had a position like
this early on in the match from a Berlin
where black had the pair of Pawns at E5
and F5 and he played like F3 and was
trying to sort of keep the position
flexible and he didn't rush to play this
F4 move
in that position so he seems to be
comfortable in a really wide variety of
positions including positions where I
would just basically just not feel
comfortable I wouldn't
I don't know if the position is good or
bad but I would be scared of it and he
very very at ease yeah the versatility
that these players have especially in
very sharp positions is is unreal and I
like I still like ironic is playing this
he's got E4 he's got Knight D3 in the
position only C7 is hanging I would
expect maybe like Rook F7 kind of
thematic move no he just goes Knight D3
he's like my threats are stronger yeah
to me the big question was what's going
on in Queen B2 Knight C7
but um and Knight D3 is a very pleasant
move most people would love to play it
if they could
yeah
absolutely well Pawn's still hanging
here you can definitely take with Knight
B2 hit the queen
and then have time to defend C7
yeah
although Bishop D4 will be in the air
once he's done that uh yeah that's why I
was kind of thinking Queen B2 because I
feel like if you defend C7
then white has time for Bishop D4
they trade off your dark squared Bishop
after you chose to put your Pawn do on
e4 and F5 and you can kind of get
blocked up as black
so he goes for it
yeah goes for the the mess I think as
you said is Justified now Rick A7
bringing the Rook over along the seventh
rank so against Bishop B6 maybe he just
plays Rook B7 like he doesn't care but
I'm always feeling like an exchange sack
is in the air
yeah very possible I I don't know I feel
like with this Knight on D3 Bishop on G7
and you got the strong a pawn right like
you absolutely do have room for uh
exchange sacrifice it's not a
compensation
yeah so you could go Bishop B6 row C7
and then Bishop C7 Knight F2 or um
Bishop B6 Rook B7 and then just look to
maybe take on B6
so white doesn't even take on B6 Gucci
just like yeah I know my Bishop's so
good I'm not even risking you sacking in
exchange here
gives up a ton of Pawns to weaken the
light squares 96 move is costing him
several I mean yeah all just to get this
light Square Bishop but he still has to
use this piece he's got to open it up at
some point with some kind of F3 G4 he's
gonna need a pawn break but in order to
execute a pawn break you need pawns
[Laughter]
he's a master of giving them all up
yeah takes a rook
all right so in theory if he could take
one of the Rooks and take the pawn on B6
would he have an advantage that you
could process
it would even still only be unclear
because black has the powerful d-pawn
which could well be compensation for an
exchange
yeah it's very unclear honestly I I
don't know I I kind of like the Pawns in
in these cases just because uh it's hard
to go wrong with pawns either you push
them or you don't right it's like it's
very straightforward and here he's got a
lot of Pawns this upon G7 that wasn't
funny why are you laughing you're making
chess really really easy for everybody
out there like now they know how to play
they either push their pawns or they
don't
I'm not saying it's easy I'm just saying
it simplifies the the equation look his
Rook is attacked he can move his Rook to
a million places right with pawns it's
simple
you only have one square you move it to
right takes away see A2 you don't have
to think about that yeah
and you're right he's building like a 40
second time lead out of the blue in this
position
right
and now Queen H5 looks active but
um does it actually have a threat I
think I guess Queen G6 right could be a
threat Bishop yeah
so there's no follow-up right maybe the
idea is if you Queen he gives check
before taking on A1 and if you play
Vision p7 then he takes your new that's
genius Queen immediately and then yeah
why is just completely winning at the
end I got like Rook A8 coming but now
he's also gotta watch his King against
those themes
nice find here by ronak Knight Queen C5
here coaster without moving the Knight
King G1
right here
C5 makes sense 20 seconds
makes sense Knight still oh he finds it
leaving the Knight hanging will he get
he gets another brilliant move let's
wait did that one count as brilliant
they both did yeah because they both
hang the knights yet are good moves
which qualifies them
that will x-clamps wow H4 whatever
check King H1
yeah just looking too
okay wait but he's got Queen G5 Rook G7
oh Queen takes F5 hold on queen queen
he's fighting against the two queens
that's true he is and the bishop could
finally come out to E4 if he played as
king to H7
dude evil Bar says White's winning what
is happening white is winning down a
queen oh my God he goes for Bishop E6
the weak light squares the weak life
squares it should be six
holy smokes and that's it Ronald resigns
gookish just won the game down a queen
that didn't make any sense
I mean the extra Queen has to account
for some
is on fire David
and I Look to go cash and he's just the
same
it's just no expression
what queen how many queens is my
opponent have I don't know all I know is
I made it him
Bishop H3
it looks like a quiet move I guess in
hot I mean I guess technically it
threatens mate in two with check
but it looked like sort of a quiet move
for your opponent having an extra Queen
and you're like let me improve my Bishop
that's been locked in for a while
David I'm I'm speechless if that game
was played in like a classical
tournament you know it would be hailed
as like one of the greatest games of all
time like it was brilliancy you know
just what a masterpiece
oh my God that was incredible I thought
radic had it when he played Queen Z5 I
was like yeah ronakin was playing well
he made a win next game yeah two
brilliant moves in a row I mean he was
he was crushing it oh but gookash is
ruthless and he takes a three-point lead
it's their biggest lead of the match
right now he's just running away with it
in the three-minute abortion
um ronic essentially just just bleeding
here heavily he needs to
bounce back as quickly as he can
needs to remember who he is
advani
that gets some points I mean he was
remembering he was he was hammering him
with brilliant moves
and then it wasn't enough yeah all of a
sudden he like he gets the second Queen
and it's yeah you think all right second
Queen
yeah resign that's where you resigned
normally right yeah okay what's happened
if you used everything traded off the
bishop on H6 so you don't have an attack
made a full extra Queen
unbelievable
so
go cash defending pretty classically
here against this uh
do they call it a jobava London yeah I
guess so yeah this is the jubava Knight
C3 Bishop F4
personally I think it should be called
the jibava verisav because it's closer
to a verisav attack than it is a London
system but you know that's that's
chessable politics you're not gonna not
gonna make any Headway there
no well I don't know I don't know you
could try and get elected
to the presidency of the opening naming
committee president of the yeah Eco
codes
yeah
okay but or or you could just say like
I'm just trying to raise awareness I'm
just I'm just one vote what can I do I'm
just one man
yeah
that's a Simpsons scene do you know that
one cost you ah
there's like an election where like the
election is decided by one vote and Sim
and and Homer doesn't vote and he just
goes on and on like but I'm just one man
what could I have done and they're like
trying to like explain to him that
I suck over so yeah if you want to just
throw your hands up and accept that it's
going to be the job of London you can do
that but I like your idea of calling it
the jobava uh verisoft so I think
you should stand up for
yeah
maybe I'll I'll make
a statement about it one day
boom boom boom boom boom Rook to the
seventh
man you would think this would have to
be an advantage for white but black has
some counter play in mind black has this
very annoying counter play against the
G2 Pawn look at this yeah opposite color
of Bishops but
um with Rooks on the board of course
these positions are super sharp anyway
and then Rook G1 is going to run into
Bishop H2
so yeah no choice
capturing things right let your opponent
capture you capture
those light squares look pretty stable
after E6 I mean
where does white have to go to win there
after E6
I mean it's not an easy attack maybe you
sort of trap that Bishop right like my
instinct is after E6 you play F4 yeah
Bishop bishop and you gotta remember we
also have three versus one on the king's
Queen side here so
big potential for a lot of past spawns
yeah okay so Bishop D6 is played
preserves the bishop rather than the
light Square control
fair enough
yeah makes sense it's very important to
have a
solid anchor Square for your Bishops in
these kinds of end games
has to figure out how to play this he's
got one active Rook but the problem is
his other Rook is kind of tied down to
this a pawn
I mean one what could be enough to
decimate White's King side
what is planned by roundock Rook F2 Rook
F1 could it be so simple
yeah like Bishop C4 improving the bishop
we see Rook F1
I think in general if you're a stronger
side you're you're happy to trade Rooks
I would have never found Bishop C4 but
now I see it I'm like oh that's a hole
in my game that's a beautiful
beautiful move yeah it just goes F4
but now now Bishop feels very much
improved put it on B5
or in D3 okay
putting pressure maybe looking for Rook
G1 Rook G5
also he defended C2 so he could avoid
The Rook trade here with Rook A6 if he
so chooses if he wants to I think I mean
I think if he traces his active Rook for
Black's passive Rook he's not winning
this end game that's not yeah not like
not looking like progress
okay so now he's looking at Rook h8 see
that one Rook is the only only thing
he's got going
but it's more than enough and if he
takes this Pawn he'll activate the
second Rook just automatically since the
H Pawn will start running so this Rook
is a real human into a good Square
The Rook H1 great again
absolutely E5
maybe slightly desperate yeah looks like
he wanted E4
yeah E4 would have been strong
oh and Raonic wants a technical solution
honestly this is his
This Is His Brilliant game this one this
is just
beautiful beautiful game he's playing
very fine technical chess yeah why is he
going for all these like crazy super
sharp I understand the kid can calculate
but you know
yeah like you can also play
end games really well and go cash is
doing the sodwani thing here I'm just
trying to rustle up some kind of counter
plays you just can't deal with the piece
Queen E5 Queen E3 and then the queen on
E3 covers G1 it's like it's like that
thing at the end of checkers a game I've
never played where you sort of like
suddenly take everything in a yeah it's
super fun actually you should you should
try yeah
um no very nice game by ironic there
just Knight finishes off of that
combination promoting the
the queen and uh we're back to a
two-point game I know why you're a fan
of this opening Coast yeah after the
last game they played in this I'm like
applauding just seeing them repeating
the opening I want to see another of
that game oh yeah gookish uh yeah it
seems like both players had no issues
with the last game you know ronic had
two queens good cash won the game
they're like yeah let's I'll take the
two queens again
doesn't get more fun than that Knight B5
engage
yeah and it's um I often see this in
Blitz matches where two players it's
almost like they're a bit stubborn it's
like they just want to repeat the line
that they play they don't want to switch
it up they want to prove that it was uh
it was playable and we get the same
complications like last game we had Rook
B1 Queen A2 Knight takes C7
ronix seeing Apple had no reason to
deviate
maybe they had oh yeah he's like I Will
Follow That Game
until the position where I had an extra
Queen but I'll follow it so quickly that
I'll have three minutes on my clock when
I get there and I'm not gonna let you
find some cheap checkmate with the
second time around
figure it out it makes sense as a theory
that makes sense as a theory and he's
got gookish like huh what am I gonna do
once we get down to that situation
he's like in the tank for a minute yeah
well you're right because he hasn't had
time to look at the game so he's like
how do I how do I improve or switch it
up he goes Queen H5 which looks
um like a potential blunder
oh yeah well for wine I mean black go
Queen takes A1 right get the two Rooks
uh for the queen okay fine goes yeah I
wouldn't take on anyone there but I
don't know if that's really what's wrong
with with Queen H5
um
but yeah comfy wasn't wasn't liking it
okay Rook F7
um
Rook F7 either I guess was not the move
let's see here apparently Knight F6 I
was thinking about Knight F6 would have
been pretty annoying then maybe Knight
can come to G4 as well oh yeah that
looks if you were thinking about Knight
F6 why didn't you tell us about it
before checking with the computer
um well I didn't know if it was best I
didn't know if it was I was just
thinking about it
all right white tries to activate the
bishop it worked last game like 50 moves
later
um so pokes at F5 nice weak Pawn
what do you think I was dead Knight F6
here
and the six looked reasonable Knight G5
also looks pretty
pretty juicy covering F5 by blocking the
queen and hitting the bishop with tempo
that's obvious answer would be for white
to tape
twice
yeah so what happens is it takes I guess
F2 is hanging at the end so takes takes
Queen takes Knight F2
he made him back down sedwani
I assume black is winning too by the way
it looks very nice for black have an
eval bar to tell you but I would assume
Black's winning based on
how black took on B2 white didn't manage
to take on C7 white played Bishop H3 to
G2
I would assume black is winning right
default bar definitely likes black but I
mean first the position is extremely
complicated and as we've seen even
having two queens is not enough to win
the game
the standard for winning just keeps
getting higher though I don't know how
much of A Swindle
that position was because I was watching
no it was just a mess yeah it was a
little mess uh and I don't think black
was actually completely winning with the
the two queens I think it was just
um it was still just like anything wow
but it's well it's interesting to think
about how the players see it because one
player might have thought oh I'm
completely winning or whatever and that
can totally change your your mindset
going into the rest of the games versus
if you think okay it was messy and you
know it happened to to lose it in the
last seconds
yeah I think their time usage suggested
that they both kind of thought that
Raonic must have had a had the advantage
towards the end of that game yeah yeah
it felt like right very nervy from
gookesh scrambling to find some play and
I mean we could see something similar
here where it's like
black is more material again
he's got the extra Pawn but clearly the
king is under pressure White's going
after F5
yeah yeah just not easy uh
the problem is Queen V5 Knight C7 so
maybe E3 would be a king's Indian Type
move
oh E3
E3 looks very interesting
definitely worth considering one minute
here for ronic
covers at Five
okay with a sort of clean move but you
you need to be in a hurry in some King's
Indian positions right it's like you
you play a normal clean move and your
opponent finds some little
Dynamics
the time is totally caught up on him too
yeah he goes back
clearly kind of unclear about how he
should be proceeding in this position
but um of course it looks nicer like and
he's got he's down two points in the
match
he's got to play not that you can even
play this position without kind of
playing for a win right it's like yeah
you just have to be active so E3 there
we go Second Time Around plays the
terrible proof suggestion
we need for check
no it looks
reasonable to me you're taking on E3
here
C7 might hang at the end but
as well as F5 so yeah stuff's coming off
and suddenly white has two connected
passers
yeah black was supposed to be up
a little bit a couple Pawns
from B2 and C4 look at this end game
equal material now opposite color
Bishops but very very sharp like we
could see both Kings possibly getting in
danger here by the way ironic defending
against any Rook C5 Bishop E6 threats
you mean The Rook on E3
Lucas lifting The Rook
recovering A4 Knight G6 now I feel like
complexity is
is agonizing
he's only four oh that's just hanging
oh he forgot about it he just resigns
immediately to get the next game in wow
ooh big blunder there from ronic
yeah it's gonna cost back to the
verisoft right back into the job of
arasov
thank you David
and now go catch playing even more
aggressive variation from black
immediate A6 this means he wants the
bishop outside the pawn chain and C5
Costa like he wants to just say your
opening is trash your night's on C3
oof it might be friends they might be
teammates but right now they're
opponents and gukash is not going to be
taking it easy he wants the whole thing
yeah
man that was that was a big big Miss
byronic I mean the position was very
difficult though I feel like he might
have lost anyway if the game had played
out so I don't think it's such a huge
thing but of course that could easily
spoil your mood right for for the rest
of the match uh feeling like such a big
big Miss
that said this is probably going to be
the final game in the three minute
portion so if he wins this one which
right now currently looks like he's
doing he's doing okay if he wins this
one and it's only two points going into
the bullet where you gotta feel like
Rana has to be a bit of a favorite in
the bullet segment given his experience
and
um how much more he plays online
AKA experience
yeah
yeah I don't I don't know I don't know
like I feel like it's hard
it's hard to be certain of who would
have the advantage in the bullet
um yeah I mean it could go find out both
ways but yeah if I'm ironic I'm gotta
feel like okay yeah gookash in the
bullet cage for 30 minutes he can't
leave the Octagon he has to play me you
know these bullet scrambles and yeah
just go after him
what's the point of this move oh G5
oh saxophone I guess 95.
okay still needs a follow-up before I
can say that I understand it
hey I'm with you I'm with you wow I mean
he sacked upon and opened up his own
King so like normally it would be like
he'd have a tactic right
he's playing for positional comp no I I
like what Black's doing now he's got
like Knight C4 coming Bishop A3 ideas
he's done some things this match let's
say that are simply too deep for me like
even if I got to sit there for another
hour or two I'd be like how the game
with where he sacked the piece that I
thought he hung the piece and put the
pawn on A2 that game for example I mean
yeah I don't know and it's impressive I
gotta say
yeah and here that somehow by sacking
the pawn he's made the white pieces and
pawn structure I don't know
Frozen or less harmonious that white
can't Advance here
weird as well
right
see maybe maybe bishop F4 to play G5 G6
right like he's forced you into the real
versatile go back to the job of Airsoft
bring the bishop back now he's uh oh
he's opened up E4
E4 Queen takes A2
not looking good for Roanoke here
no I guess D3 could be a powerful break
at the right time E3 yeah good crush is
just
feeling it right now
Knight C4 oh man it's pouring simpler
it is absolutely boring we were talking
about maybe a two-point lead it could be
a four point lead because now it looks
like gukesh is just crushing this
position
yeah I would think Rook a to C8 here
just one more ingredient
next piece in
yeah
Rook ac-8 would threaten
something like Knight B2 Queen B2 Bishop
A3 Knight A3 Rook C3 Knight C2 Rook C2
King C2 and second Rook to C8
there's a huge line apology but he just
takes
um just takes last night because if the
Knight comes out he's got Queen A1 check
minimum
oh I think he's got Bishop E3 if the
Knight takes that's a much simpler
variation that I've missed Knight C3
Bishop E3 Knight C3 Bishop E3 the queen
takes you made if the king comes up you
made
so just Bishop takes F6 Bishop E3
Queen B2
King comes out has to be made Rick dates
brilliant move sacking one Rook but King
takes Knight B5 is gonna be Checkmate he
resigns for a similar pattern of control
to uh goofeld's Immortal game
with the King running around taking the
Knight
exactly that's a big win for gookesh now
I'm gonna be up four points going into
the one plus one score product
definitely unhappy about that
it's uh
oh man he has his word cut out for him
he has to make a four-game lead
wants to win today going to the break
down four
all kinds of things are possible in
bullet
but it's gonna have to be a little bit
one-sided he's gonna need a streak
so we'll be back in a couple minutes
folks to uh see
if uh if ronak has it has it in him to
just take over and bullet
[Music]
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
in game we've added a new classification
called Miss for when a move fails to
take advantage of an opportunity but it
is otherwise a sound move we've also
changed the definition of blunder now a
move will only be considered a blunder
if it loses material or allows a
Checkmate coach will now draw arrows and
highlight squares when you hover over or
click on the highlighted words in the
move explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to the junior
speed chess championships of 2023 we are
now not only in the final match we're in
the final portion the bullet 30 minutes
of unrestrained one plus one action
coming up new cash has taken a
considerable lead here four points the
biggest lead of the match so far roundac
incredible bullet player
um costia your thoughts is he is he in
range
um
let's say this gookash has like
actualized you know as a as a chess
player right he's just firing in all
cylinders he was playing well the whole
match we saw at the beginning he was
having trouble converting against
ronic's slippery defense but he since
kind of fixed that issue now he's
converting his positions he's got a huge
lead going into the bullet
um but of course it's not going to be
easy ronic is a bit high rated and
bullet definitely a favorite has more
experience and also he's very hungry
chronic and already uh lost once in the
finals to nihal sarin two years ago in
2021 I don't think he wants to repeat
that I'm pretty sure he wants to win and
for that he's gonna have to turn it up
in the bullets
yeah he's going to have to
um
you know ronox bullet prowess is perhaps
better known he is the number six bullet
player on chess.com right now
with an insane rating in the region of
3184 or something like that
um
so he's very very uh well known for that
for that bullet power but when I was
looking in the break at gukesh's own
bullet performance I saw more than 200
rating points gained in the last month
um and
you know I think that although he
doesn't have a ton of practice in the in
uh in his history
it looks like he's also
a top bullet player if he chooses to be
so
it's streaky but I think you could
probably that two to one on on gukash
being able to hold on to his onto his
lead
and there we go they started the one one
and they're back to the king's Indian
they've been discussing this for a while
now guest switches to The Exchange
variation
switching it up and the bullet portion
here and Yeah ironic is going to have to
start off fast it's only 30 minutes it's
definitely enough time to mount a
comeback but it's not a lot of time
so yeah
do or die I mean ironic here ronak has
to I would say dominate right it's not
enough to just win this section
um he's got a really really power
through
and as you said googesh is really on
form at the moment but good for him
bullet is basically the most volatile of
the time controls it's like you lose one
game and it's like boom you got to start
the next game and you're you're down to
55 seconds you know it's just no time to
recover so yeah you're gonna pull time
it's no time to adjust an opening or
anything like that right it's just go go
go
throughout
oh the trades off those dark squared
Bishops and then things better of it
never mind then gookish offers the
repetition a little cheeky just let him
know
oh no yeah
thanks to going through a lot of the
most brilliant games in chess history
together I'm aware that Knight D5 would
be a way for white to show the strength
of the C5 Pawn
absolutely in these positions you've got
that space on the queen side it's like
but what's it good for what can you
attack on the queen side ooh speaking of
95 Knight D4 from black I think is
winning material because he can take on
G4 exactly and then white has two pieces
here
nicely spotted by ironic winning the
exchange
and one of the first mistakes we've seen
from gilcash maybe a little bit
sign of the switch to Bullet
yeah I mean it's very easy to to blunder
that he's playing on seconds but uh okay
big first chance here for ronic if you
can get that first win I think that will
really calm him down he's like okay
that's the start
yeah also I think he can keep playing
the king's Indian uh throughout this
bullet push oh Rook C1 Bishop C3 Rook C3
Rook D1 would be death oh Rick C1 yeah
it doesn't seem to have any move what
else can you do here the Knight is
hanging he takes gives up The Rook
I mean 96 but
I mean definitely one just forces the
Queens off and yeah gookish I think is
going to be playing these out right he
wants to uh take time off the clock
makes sense at this point from a match
perspective
um
I'm in Europe Four Points you're trying
to win a spot in the speed chess
championships fifteen thousand dollars
yeah might as well take your chances
and yeah he is being very clear about it
normally these guys they were like
resigning you know as the position was
like kind of collapsing you know we can
see okay it's losing now it's like yeah
yeah no no you gotta win with your he's
not running out his time he's playing so
fast shouldn't he use these 17 seconds
um yeah actually he got himself mated
there
one I think he did it on purpose too I
think it was like a way of resigning hmm
oh he was looking for no no he played
really fast Coast yeah looking for this
now I don't have much experience with
bullets so tell me if I'm wrong but he
played really fast instead of using his
time to get round eye playing really
fast as well and then set a stalemate
trap yeah exactly he's trying to Eric
Rose and him but veronic has been Eric
Rosen before you know he can't he can't
fool him too many times I'm sure they uh
they all have
um yeah it was worth the shot it was
worth the shot I mean that the 15
seconds is not going to be
um I think so so crucial it's not a good
cushion he can't just Coast to Victory
he's got to win bullet games if he wants
to win this match you can't just defend
and get some draws in bullet you have to
actually
beat your opponent
um he played that whole game very
defensively actually like he was playing
white he was offering draws in the
opening
um so he might need to find a more
aggressive mode for this bullet section
actually so it's a three-point game and
look at this he's down 30 seconds
already in game two
absolutely putting the pressure on
five okay offering some trades very
solid kind of Berlin line 92 keeping
more pieces on the board
I think that makes a lot of sense
because both the Black Knights are kind
of fighting for the same F5 Square
oh see the clock is so telling I mean 57
seconds against 20. you can see that
roundach is trying to is playing Super
confidently and trying to get a lot of
games in potentially
or just put a lot of pressure on gukesh
and gukash is sort of like struggling to
keep up with that pace so he's using at
this time he's not comfortable he's
trying to Blitz him off the board
if I owe cd5 that's hanging
there's a pawn boy Veronica this is just
a demolition in this game
yeah
one the previous one too right so it's
uh off to an incredible start here in
these two games yeah yeah
very strong start from ronic now Bishop
B2 ukush needs to turn on a faster mode
here
yeah he's also switching to some
aggressive play here with G5 right so
he's maybe the bad position is what he
needs
to really switch gears and start playing
aggressive Dynamic moves
there we go that kind of a move
yeah maybe bishop on D7 first would have
been prudent but you know
we just don't have time for correct
chest and bullet
yeah it's not a science
oh my God
oh God I don't know if I can watch this
thing that's not a science this is worse
than that they were using that video
they were playing with like the pieces
getting crushed this is more violent
than that
oh my Lord he's pushing oh but it's hard
Knight H4 giving the Knight just to
trade the Queens off the board that
would have been a nice combo now he's
looking for rookie eight in the position
just to promote them on I mean it's you
can still get mated here as well yeah
Knight G3 you know
immediately immediately just coming in I
think Queen G6 and rookie eight would
work here allowing Queen H4 oh there's
okay he's done something else that works
there's gotta be made Knight F4 yeah
winning the queen yeah
still fighting but ironic is going to
take this one as well
oh King comes in
can you avoid getting mated
oh no chance
no chance make incoming on the H file
the flags as next was going to be Bishop
H2 Rook H2 Rana two zero in the bullet
The Comeback is melting
okay come back is mounting
let's see if gookish can play this game
normal let's say right aggressive and
fast
first of all he didn't go for D takes E5
he's back to the complicated variation
that's right that's a big change
immediately
yeah going for more
and a principled approach but so far
ronic has shown a lot of
a lot of skills in these Kings Indian
positions
oh yeah
oh I I get the feeling he's he's feeling
comfortable here I don't know why gooka
switched away from the Berlin honestly
I'm not getting it I feel like he was
putting ronic Under Pressure there in
the structure the bishop takes C6
yeah yeah
he seemed comfortable
he knows what he's doing
3b4 yeah
oh and eight positions are nightmares to
me so complicated tuck the bishop on B2
Knight's gonna come to D4 I guess so
it's not totally
swimming
yeah at Night comes back to D4 other
Knight jumps to G5 very active position
for black all you gonna try to maybe
push e for it's oh it's very hard
against the bishop on V2 oh and F4
ukesh
wow see this is what he needs why not it
works he's exactly with some confidence
this game now he's yeah he's woken up
he's like oh I need to win this game
yeah yeah it's like oh I understand now
yeah
three time controls three segments it's
not enough to just be like oh yeah I had
a great start
yeah looking great for
gookish here blacks Indian nights maybe
administering Checkmate may be doing
nothing we'll find out oh D4 is Queen F2
in that position gukash just showing
zero fear
over here
Queen F4 with a slightly worse end game
we have four and then Knight F2
very possible now he pulls back
it's more like running Knight F2
okay King G2 would be a draw for but
he's thinking twice here because now he
wants to win you know like of course
yeah good position's good that's what
you need to do
yeah we need two Bishop D7 just trying
to get that rook in 96
coming in if takes takes Bishop F7 check
will happen you're gonna have to sack in
exchange if you take here
whoa uh ironic oh
the queen
uh he just looked at some Bishop E6
variations so deep rejected it and then
forgot that in the starting position he
was looking at Bishop E6 because his
Queen was attacked okay okay Rana is
showing signs of life that must be a
very relieving point for gukesh because
it's now three-point game 19 minutes
left
and he knows he's not the only one
blundering in the bullet portion all
right roundock uncorks a very aggressive
line against
the Berlin
sacking the d-pawn right out of the
gates grabbing the bishop pair
look at this yeah you can go Bishop F4
and black will probably leave the Knight
there and then you could play
technically but generally that's not
what you're looking for is white here
it's like the E file the threats against
the king side
the E7 Square could
tempt him
oh wow okay
Black's Pawn structure not winning any
awards this season
couldn't get Rookie seven though because
rookie seven Rook d8 Bishop C4 D5 and
King f8 you get evicted so
he's gonna have to play a long end game
here and I think rookie eight very smart
I think the Brooks come off you know
it's hard to go after these double pawns
right without a rook for whites
exactly
so and four pawns on dark squares plus a
light squared Bishop
it's hard to see White's King's entry
point
yeah
and he's down a pawn
though he could win somehow if he
manages like a bishop trade where his
King then ends up munching all of black
spawns so so you're saying secretly go
cash could try to win this end game at
some point as black no I'm thinking why
why you could have chances just with the
more active King possibly
won't be easy won't be easy
we haven't had a lot of end games in
this match looks very solid
we've had very few like straight up like
you know Bishop end games nine ending
games
yeah
three ronic still pushing F6
yeah this game could suck a lot of life
out of the out of the match clock cost
yeah yeah like a true end game if you
play you know
90 moves on a one second increment and
lose an extra three minutes out of the
match right
that's the watch is playing quite
quickly roundock honestly
I feel like it would have been better if
there was some way for him to just agree
to a draw
um and get out of that game
so draw agreed yeah that could have been
a lot more time off the clock
he's fully committed to the King's Inn
and he's even willing to play the Pierce
yeah yeah I know that game
[Laughter]
anything to put the bishop on on G7 no
it's been working for him I think really
nicely so far despite losing that last
game but um yeah for the most part he's
been getting very very decent position
since yeah it's important in bullet to
be able to play openings that you can
can play quickly and reasonably
yeah he's got a great drag in this game
as well so the Pierce didn't offer him
any particular difficulties
it was a bishop game 16 minutes on the
clock still ample still ample you'd
think uh four or five games to go
that's right
I like gokash's position here I feel
like he's doing
doing well now B4 gaining space
it's nine on D5 sitting very nice
yeah each form pressure trying to make
E7 really uncomfortable often in these
positions you play F6 at some point
but without a light squared Bishop I
think that's much less of an option than
usual or maybe even not an option
so how to reduce the pressure we're
coming in
no good
don't feel happy about that no
okay he played F6
yeah ooh F4
kukash knows his position is good
yeah he can win this one good to keep
one night on for white
Knight B6 was really good I think really
important to keep one night on the board
for white hair now 97 oh man he's he's
just desperately trying to challenge
this Knight yeah really reaching Knight
comes back okay now he says you can take
but then Edie opening up the e-file
right at least trying to say the Knight
on C8 would then be trapped on on C8 not
begin not be able to get out of the way
all right clean Bishop pair every Pawn
moved off to Second rank for the king
reduces some of your options it
definitely looks tough
looking for Rook D7 now Knight P5 stops
it
20 seconds four nice move
inviting the clean trade but then
White's end game is just going to be
excellent
inviting and more or less forcing it
right and the poor Knight has also been
separated from his team
in that but Brown act finds the resource
and keeps the game going he's slippery
he's still playing Bishop A7 you get
like a winning advantage on the queen
side but there will be counter play
against your king now
right now you can lose right like things
get oh oh he's got Bishop E3 though Rana
can lose
that's probably not after finding that
beautiful oh no excellent game by good
cash
okay setting up a famous mate awesome
some checks
yeah or at least some checks if not a
mate
now extra exchange for
good cash Knight C3 in the position yeah
he needs to just protect the king and
then the a pawn should win the game for
him but
still some work to do
C6 coming that's it ronic resigns
probably to save time
yeah I thought in general in that
position he could just play Rook take C5
at any point and win with the a pawn
against the poor Knight
Black Tie he just calculated the tactics
kept The Rook on the seventh Advanced
the eighth one
yeah but that makes it four points again
for gukesh and so far it's two and a
half two and a half in the bullet you
know ronic is not dominating the way
yeah he thought he would need to to come
back yeah he came out of the gates
killing but now he's on the border of
losing the match I think it's very very
close
all minutes left on the clock yeah at
this point he's just racing Against Time
itself
which is a difficult battle
in solid you see that nobody ever wins
that one
yeah
the huge Queen side
or black you need to ironic's up on the
clock he's up to 109.
wow trying to get as much time as
possible daunting even higher gear this
is the ultra bullet
rate of play yeah super fast
but uh I like his position very much I
mean
everything is still positionally so
pristine Coast yet like
I'm noticing things they're doing that
are
you know big big amazing deals you know
like black playing H5 why because if
white plays H5 then you're H7 pawns a
weakness right so he like throws that in
on his weak side
um just at this rate it's crazy
watch out for that mate yeah he he
defends against it but now black is
going after the second rank I feel like
we've seen this before
with ronic Knight C4 is too strong this
position's dead like he had Rook f8 to
F2 or he had B4 threatening Knight
um Knight B2
um
oh no look at this
Rook on H1 is hanging take take a rookie
Eights
resigns
[Music]
oh man this it's almost over now it's
Five Points yeah
Five Points I think he can basically
run out the clock
yeah he's looking he's looking
Unstoppable ronic basically just has to
play instantly and perfectly if he wants
to come back you could go back to that
defensive mode that cost him the first
two games of this bullet match
playing simpler moves that aren't maybe
as good taking your time might be enough
to run out the clock
but yeah at this point it's um
it's looking very very good for good
cash
yeah we're hearing uh 90 win rate for
him
I agree huge honestly feels even higher
for me I don't know I don't think Rana
comes back 10 of the time
uh mind-boggling King's Indian
positioned meanwhile
yeah I guess a pretty clean exchange
sack for white where that Bishop's gonna
be worth the exchange
this is not pretty
this is not I mean this bishop is uh is
a monster on the diagonal this was
probably a good and careful move he
played here because the thing I could
imagine going wrong would be you get
tied up by rookie eight
and then maybe you play F3 to not lose
the Knight on e4 but then you're loose
with the Rook on E1 and
I think this was reasonable just to
just back up
I like Knight G3 looking to get the
queen in
big Stakes takes on F5 okay I'm feeling
some back rank issues for white hair
yeah hold on Queen H5 Queen H5 oh what a
move and 93 Queen D1
oh no G4 he finds the only defense oh
that that clears the back rank
what a friend by ironic and now you know
Queen D4 what what's happening even
right
probably be rookie five so he tries to
get the queen out of the way of that
first takes to each Pawn now Black's
King just completely empty
and then he blocks the file for The Rook
evil
pure evil 18 seconds to 40 seconds is it
using up in the clock time it is White's
King is very much uh I think in the open
here yeah oh Rook G8 wanna move Queen H4
yeah King head somewhere weird
Queen H4 Pawn takes Knight and then what
no I was thinking some checks maybe yeah
it was this way but now gokish has two
pieces for the rook and if you can just
save his King I think yeah I think it's
just
a disaster for Black Knight on E3
brilliant play like the safe looking
Queen D3 move he just went for mate he
said like I'm just gonna stick with what
works which is trying to cut his head
off instead of trying to defend what I
have exactly
and this is just or he can go for the
end game in fact and take a lot of time
off the clock while he wins taking an A4
and you have to like resign just because
you can't spend the time on this end
game
oh we hung The Rook yeah Rook was
hanging I think he's still hanging he
sees it the second time
oh no poor ronic yeah we're on it but I
think that's it David yeah we got eight
minutes left six point lead no there's
no way now yeah
there's no way
also it looks like gookash
the you know
top Prodigy who doesn't play random
online Blitz who doesn't like work with
computers very much
is uh quite competent at playing
speeches on a computer he's like on his
way to being a top five bullet player
yeah with this swiveled experience it
definitely doesn't seem like bullet is
you know a huge priority for gukesh he
plays a lot of classical tournaments but
you know clearly the kid the kid can
play in I think just somewhere in the
three minute portion you know he he won
six and a half two and a half right he
just really started taking over and yeah
Roddick showed glimpses right in the in
the first first couple bullet games but
then then gookish came back to his roots
of just playing the best moves every
time no matter what and uh yeah it's
hard strategy to deal with
yeah I mean many people have complained
when their opponents use that strategy
right and uh here we've got some dueling
night outposts
uh
yeah
all about who gets their Rooks active I
think in these sort of double stone
walls
yeah now it does look like gookesh is
going to be the winner but that doesn't
mean that these games are pointless
actually there's still quite a bit of
money on the line they are splitting the
second half of the prize fund 7 500
based on every single uh win and point
in the match so
yeah each one of these games is worth
several trips to McDonald's Froyo I mean
it's like it's a lot of stuff 300 a
point
at least I think something like that so
that's uh
that's pretty good for a one minute uh
bullet game
yeah
and kukesh is still just playing very
very nice moves throughout here
oh yeah well he's chilling I mean he's
got uh he's in control Queen on D5 looks
nice to me
at a certain point is going to have more
time left on his clock
then
uh points that Rana can make up yeah oh
and he wins again oh no yeah it was a
mouse slip I think Queen D2 instead of
Queen D3 maybe but
I don't know it was weird he was in a
commanding position
I think
in anything just going
yeah wrong Veronica
well it was a fun match for you cost you
you got a good number of King's Indian
games here
yeah a lot of fun Kings Indians I think
these games are very much worth
um worth looking at ronic is uh he's
definitely a Kings Indian
uh aficionado
and he goes back for this thing which
yeah honestly the first time around look
very very risky okay very surprised that
he's repeating it
well he's got an innovation in mind
Knight G5 novelty on move 20 here
bullet is bullet has changed Coast yes
since my days
and just opening knowledge in general
like the level of everything is like
what I don't think this is opening now
at least not according to the the eval
bar
doesn't seem to be
approved okay okay
well maybe you can't repeat all of these
opening ideas in a classical tournament
but
F4 oh what queen takes F4
or I think he wants either Knight H5 or
maybe Queen H5 oh man give it a rest it
must be Queen H5 jeez yeah
as you say he's never like slowing down
or lighting up huh
three
all right he wants everything I love it
when he doesn't play any simple moves
when everything is some concrete move
that I wouldn't have seen it really like
reminds me how I should try to play
chess
yeah and ronic you're just resigning I
actually think that makes a lot of sense
look the match the match is over gukesh
is winning but the more games ronic wins
the more money he gets out of the match
yeah but might as well but if gukesh
wins six of them in a row he can
preserve his percentage by just running
out the clock himself despite losing the
match because you'll get his uh he's
just not killing here he's not gonna
wrap the clock
ukesh is uh he's a pal he's a chess
player
um yeah incredible performance by gukesh
today we saw I mean he he started off
slow but
since then he's just stayed focused
hasn't moved from his seats and
yeah he's gonna remain focused in his
next
20 to 30 years of his career yeah I mean
we say you know oh there's this at stake
there's that at stake you know but he's
already won whatever's at stake today
and you see him approaching the games
just the same as before right so it's
it's almost like he's in a constant mode
right he's in a constant you know do the
most
then you possibly can
every game matters you always have to
do your best yeah
fantastic
um now this game to the position at hand
is he down a pawn
yeah officially down upon
uh is black
how do you get his Rick to B3 yeah it
must have gone through the corpse of the
D4 Pawn
when when we blinked away for a second
that's E5 or rookie two oh Queen D4 go
cash with the tactics
really not lighting up indeed yeah
holy moly
this is fantastic
this is fantastic what a killer
a domination now Queen takes F2 looks
like a pretty good spot
everything hanging in White's position
is putting on
putting on a clinic here
one minute left in the match clock
we might get another game depending if
veronic decides to resign this one or
knots
a year ago the Olympiad had not yet been
played
oh my God rugby two and Knight C4 goes
oh what a tactic a year ago at this time
the Olympian had not yet been played and
there were people who didn't know go
cash
just one year ago
YouTube
okay ronic trying to save this end game
but
he's down upon and yeah positioned not
looking good two of them
oh two pawns yeah on each side of the
board
he's fighting Rook F3
yeah
okay sure just putting on
absolutely mental performance I think
the match clock is going to keep him
from Crossing 3200 he might only get six
points for this game
but
uh yeah
it's quite a ball it's gonna do it
time's up
yeah ukesh is the official winner 2023
Junior speed Chess Championship
qualifying to the overall speed Chess
Championship taking place later this
year where he's going to go up against
likes of Magnus Carlson and the greatest
players in the world and of course
winning the better part of fifteen
thousand dollars in today's prize money
oops they're gonna close this game out
yeah he just made the first mistake I've
seen in a really long time ghost yeah
yeah
he's kind of yeah he lost control here
now White's uh Apon is very strong
definitely looks like the bishop is is
better than the knights but Bishop's
taking everything yeah Bishop he's gonna
lose the game H5 and
yeah it looks like ronic's gonna pick up
the final game and that's it go cash
resigns wow is wrong with the final game
but
he still becomes the champion 2023
Junior speed Chess Championship
wow fantastic that's good amazing
performance performance
um yeah
the match was very competitive early on
then at some point
just showed that he was Stronger today
um and we will hopefully have a chance
to uh speak with him uh in just a couple
minutes so stick around folks
and uh
okay
um so uh here you can see how he made
his way from the first round to the
final round all the participants fared
we had very very good performance for
the Indian players winning all
quarterfinal matches
all three Indians made it to the
semifinals
and uh gookesh
wins all his matches by more than five
points
yeah amazing performance by ronic as
well getting to the finals just to lose
uh to guke she lost once before to
knee-haul I'm sure this one will sting
as well but I mean I think he has
nothing to be
too upset about he played an amazing
match he had some amazing games and
gukas just was in slightly better form
uh and towards the end
and uh yeah yeah I was absolutely
impressed with roundup's play today
absolutely
super impressive
um folks I think we're gonna go to a
break we'll have an interview with the
winner uh gookesh or your questions in
the chat we'll pick some of the best
ones and possibly ask them on air
stick around and we'll be back in just a
bit
foreign
[Music]
into the New York City subway set up a
table on the subway platform and see if
we get some strangers waiting for their
trains to play chess with us
[Music]
all right now I'm gonna see if I can get
anybody
[Music]
sounds like he knows what he's doing a
little bit
don't worry I'm not that good yeah
you're just out here playing chess not
that good got the chess.com app
you ever play on your phone oh yeah he
said he barely played I'm a teacher what
do you teach chess I'm just kidding
self-defense how do you stay sane
take medication
what's like lesson 101 of self-defense
one what are you listening to right now
train
Sean Paul Ed Sheeran what is the meaning
of life it's funny because like what I'm
doing I feel like doesn't align with my
philosophy on what the meaning of life
is but it's like obviously spent as much
time with family as possible the best
person you can be you're closer to God
not to be evil to each other
good game thanks for playing
good games
I'll see you in a self-defense class
enjoy Harry Styles
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to chess.com's
coverage of the 2023 Junior speed chess
championships it have now been concluded
with the victory of Grandmaster gukesh
ukash congratulations and thank you for
joining us
yeah thank you
um we have some questions here from
coast and myself as well as from the
audience
um it was fantastic fantastic match we
just we just watched my first question
for you is when you're playing chess do
you ever think about things other than
chess like do you think about results or
like if I win this I get to play in the
this the main speed Chess Championship
or I get to win money or is there
anything else that you think about while
you're playing
um sometimes this uh these goals do come
up come up in your head
but I mean in Blitzen bullet it's hard
to think about anything else things are
happening so fast so
yeah I wasn't really I was quite focused
uh today in today's matchup
yeah big congrats I feel like you both
played an amazing match today I was
wondering if you made any conscious uh
adjustments throughout the match we
noticed you started off with like E4
going for the Berlin then you switched
to D4 you guys got a lot of Kings
Indians and you started having these
heavy battles was there some kind of
strategy behind that or how did you kind
of approach uh the opening choices and
those kind of decisions
yeah I want the G4 I just wanted
a slow game I know that he plays Berlin
I I thought and bloodshed would be hard
for him to play this kind of slow
positions but uh yeah it wasn't really
working out well I was taking up too
much time without space It was kind of
hard for me to play as well so
I thought the with three minutes it will
not make much sense to just continue
with the plan so I switched in between
he was first playing
response and then
by the second game already he had to
start winning games so he switched to
Kings India
we got some funny funny theoretical
battles but this went uh deep into
[Music]
there's two games uh
after all this queen Beetle stuff and I
think I was just worse but for some
reason I kept repeating it
and I won both those games
you won the first game where you were uh
you were down a queen when you won the
first game was that can you tell us a
little bit about your thoughts in that
game like did you think you're winning
or losing or
foreign
at some point I guess but
but okay it was a time scramble and both
are things are exposed there are a lot
of stuff happening so it's just uh
who comes it comes up with uh
better transplants
yeah
quite a nice move just being down
it's a nice nice
thing to take a player
yeah I guess in five seconds you just it
was very hard for him to find anything
to stop them but uh I don't know maybe
already the position was
not winning
I have no idea
yeah that one was one of the most fun to
watch for for uh you know us and for for
the fans as well people are going crazy
watching that game
um I want to ask you about another game
that blew my mind which was the game
where you sacked uh your Bishop on A6 to
bring your Pawn to A2
and you had like Queen and rook and Pawn
on A2 and he had Queen and rook and
Bishop
um and we were just wondering like were
you confident that this was a good
sacrifice that it was that it was
winning
um
it couldn't be 100 sure but it was like
uh it was a squid and Rook are just
and I saw that you can't take the pawn
that Bishops before
I thought
it just should be good I I couldn't uh
see the concrete but it was more of an
intuitive thing
but anyways I think
um yeah in a few seconds it's hard for
him to find the right difference if if
there was one
I would say practically
yeah I think Coast just saw the
evaluation bar and saw that it was
completely correct and winning and but
to me who wasn't watching the evaluation
bar when I saw you do it like I I
couldn't believe it it was just stunning
yeah
if it was corrective it feels even
better
yeah yeah it was
you've uh you've won a lot of stuff now
but now you're the 2023 Junior speed
chess uh Champion you got to win several
tough matches uh to get here uh is does
this have does this title have a special
meaning for you
oh surely yeah this is so
it's some strong openness
[Music]
it was a good match
well known
Blitz and bullet players
I mean I mainly played uh for some
practice in the faster than controls
but uh yeah the way I played the way I
dominated both the snatches
yeah it's really special and
uh
I'm more known to be a slow player
classical uh
uh I've recently started working for
faster tank controls as well and
yeah I'm happy that
yeah seems to be working very quickly
um we've got some really excellent
questions lots of people in chat had
great questions we picked out a couple
of them to pass on to you so this first
one is from advice Kumar and they ask
how do you manage to make a comeback in
each of these last two matches where you
started out down
a couple games
I guess uh
at the start I just couldn't find the
return my I played at a very bad pace
in time scramble so I couldn't get my
mind to think fast and it was just I
think
trouble just just warming up but once I
was warmed up I think I
I didn't quite well
maybe I have to play a few games before
the night starts I just go with the flow
but uh yeah yeah I mean I started with
two losses and I mean the laws are drawn
then I lost but but still quite
confident
that
it I mean it's a long match there are so
many games to play so I knew that I'll
get my chances and I just have to find
my find my floor
uh yeah once I did
quite smooth
maybe maybe an adaptation for the speed
trust Championship so you can lose one
or two Blitz Games online right before
your match starts and get it out of the
way
yeah maybe winning uh two games first
results
yeah
be there um go cash another
um feature chat question from you from
uh Barb Mitzvah what do you consider to
be your greatest strength
um
I would say my competition
it has been my
my main strength for uh
few years
I really have a lot of confidence in my
calculation
and then Blitz uh it's kind of hard to
calculate a lot
I have to trust my intuition more as
well so
uh I would say one of my biggest trends
like congratulations
[Music]
yeah absolutely
um our next question comes from
Grandmaster Robert Hess who often
commentates your matches and uh he would
love to hear if there's anyone that you
would find it most fun or that you would
most want to play in the speed Chess
Championship main event
it's almost fun to play against practice
simply because it's the it's the best
player in the world
and last time I played and it was not so
fun but
but I
am but I still enjoy playing against
them if I get a chance I I hope to do
better than last time
[Music]
yeah yeah I I would love to see you play
him again I think that would be an
awesome match as well
um one more question here from the chat
this one from pumpkin the cat so we
heard when you were growing up for a
very long time you were working without
engines as you were developing uh your
chest until you became a quite a strong
player
the question is what was it like
learning without chess computers
it was uh it was something that my
trainer
suggested
it was just an experiment actually and
we always thought once I get the certain
level will start using using engines but
till that point it was like just
notebooking with computer and sometimes
might sometimes my trainer
when we are working on openings we would
a few videos engines and I'll just set a
thing called
I think one of the that that was one of
the reasons
why my calculations so so good because I
I uh I just used to calculate every
position
I just went deep into everything
that is one of
one of the advantage but
but maybe there were some
yeah
some something I could have
been better at with
it's hard to say but so
yeah it's it was a very interesting
experiment
but I would like to think
I think it worked out I think we we
think it worked out well for for you and
your in your chest absolutely yeah
um so uh good cash we just want to thank
you so much um for playing all all the
matches it's a great joy for all of us
to watch we're all here for you so thank
you so much congratulations on winning
and uh best of luck in all your next
events
thank you
all right and folks here you have it the
completed bracket for the 2023 Junior
speed chess championships uh today we've
watched the championship match with
bukash defeating ronak sedwani a score
of 17 and a half to ten and a half after
a tide uh five in one portion a four and
a half to four and a half we started to
pull away in the 3-1 and he uh also
managed to win the bullet nicely as well
here are the final prizes for all the
players coaster you can
uh tell us about the money
yeah a lot of uh nice prizes won uh well
21 and a half thousand for goo cash for
coming into first 12 000 for ronik
sedwani for his second place finish
um 4 500 for lazavic who came in third
thirty seven hundred uh for pranav in
terms of fourth they were both knocked
down in the semis I think it's just the
listings of the prize money folks the
reason why these figures are a little
bit uneven is because the matches are
divided based on who wins how many games
they get to split a portion of the
prizes and we can see each of the
players was able to get a nice little
chunk of change for their efforts here
in the junior speed Chess Championship
yeah and uh before we leave you folks
we'd like to let you know about
something else that's coming up this
week a very special event
it is Blitz Champs 2 the most highly
anticipated chess pro athlete crossover
returns this week with champs two
features the likes of Larry Fitzgerald
Jr returning Blitz Champs champion
chidobe ausier and more of the NFL's
finest chess players and you can join
Danny wrench and John Urschel and
watching it all go down this Friday from
12 p.m noon until 5 00 PM Eastern so
something to mark on your calendars for
this week
um Coast yeah it's been a lot of fun
what a great match
on a match
always amazingly always lovely to watch
go cash play chess whether it is uh
classical chess or bullet
and ronic as well I mean they both
played some amazing games today I feel
like I could certainly learn from each
of them like who catches calculation his
clear-headedness ironic's
resourcefulness and his is trickery I
mean it was really an amazing final I'm
very grateful to have gone in the chance
to call it with you David shout out to
the chat super fun to have a bunch of
people watching shout out to the dojoers
as well in the chat always great to see
support from the dojo yeah and uh yeah
hopefully we get another chance yeah
nice to see you all thank you everybody
for watching with us and joining us for
these events and supporting these events
uh quick thanks to chess kid or for
being a sponsor for the junior speed
Chess Championship and bringing us this
event
um great work from all the mods and our
producer so uh thank you everybody have
a great day we'll see you around
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]